JULY TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
MEETING. TO START I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF OF MADE A
RETURN TO THE CAPITOL POSSIBLE
TO COVER NINETEEN
CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
HERE IN THIS TOURNAMENT
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL. SO WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON WE REQUIRE THAT MUST BE
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED. BY ALL INDIVIDUALS-
WITHIN THE CAPITAL IT IS THE
CUSTOM OF THE HOUSE THE MEMBERS
BE PROPERLY ATTIRED IN FOR
HEARING WEARING A MASK IS ALSO
A REQUIREMENT OF BEING PROPERLY
ATTIRED. WE HAVE A BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY ONE IS ON CONSENT.
WE ASK FOR EACH BILL- TO ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION EACH MAIN WITNESS
WILL GET UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH.
M. PLEASE BE ADVISED FOR ALL OF
THE WITNESSES CON AND TO
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
WE ASK THAT YOU ONLY STATE YOUR
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. IF YOU
SEE MORE THE OPERATOR WILL CUT
YOU OFF IF YOU CAN'T GET
THROUGH ON THE PHONE. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE THIS
WILL BECOME PART OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE BILL YOU
CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN EMAIL TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. WE'VE A COUPLE
OF OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY FROM MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A LIMITED NUMBER.
OF MEMBERS- WITHIN THIS ROOM
AND AS I SAID. IF ANY MEMBER
THE PUBLIC WISHES TO TESTIFY TO
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
AND ASK YOU TO. APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. FOR FOLKS IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY ROOMS ARE STATIONS
WHICH IS LOCATED ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF THE CAPITOL GROUNDS.
THESE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
TESTIMONY LIFE. WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH WITNESSES
CAN TESTIFY TO BILL. THE
CALLING NUMBER WHICH IS ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE IN
ON YOUR TELEVISION SCREEN. IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. IF YOU CALL IN PLEASE
DO SO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON BEGINS
THEIR PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST AND SMART DEVICES TO
REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION. AND BE
ADVISED IF YOU ARE THE MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST A BILL YOU REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE. IT WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF INTO YOUR CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE. AT. NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT
FIVE. MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
TRY TO HELP. AND AGAIN I'LL
NOTE THAT WE ARE WILL ACCEPT
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LITTLE PORTAL. ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE AND AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND UNDERSTANDING. AND
I SEE I THINK WE'RE ONE VOTE
SHORT OF A QUORUM SO WE'LL WAIT
FOR ONE MORE MEMBER TO COME
BEFORE WE STASHING QUORUM BUT
UNTIL THAT HAPPENS WE WILL
PROCEED. AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
WILL TAKE UP QUORUM SHORTLY AND
SO TO BE HEARD AND FOLLOWER-
OUR FIRST ITEM TODAY IS S. B.
E. TWELFTH BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
CENTER WALK. MISTER CHAIR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
ACTUALLY WE CAN JUST ESTABLISH
CORSICA'S CORN JUST WALKED IN-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ISSUE HERE HERE THEY ARE
STILL HERE THEY ARE THEY HERE
APRIL. ALL OVER- KILEY MAY. X.
SILVA. THANKS TO BE HERE WE
WEEKS HERE AND IF WE CAN'T-
TAKE A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
ITEM. MADAM SECRETARY. MOTIONS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN APPROPRIATIONS. CHIU
HI Q. I SAY ARE THERE HI C. R.
HI GABRIELLE. KALRA KALRA AYE
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN CORK SILVA
THANKS TO BUY WICKS WICKS I
THANK FOR MUCH AND NOW BACK TO
THE GOOD CENTER PLEASE WITH
YOUR PRESENTATION AS CHAIR I
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT FOR ALLOW
ME TO BE HERE TODAY MEMBERS
IT'S GOODTO SEE OBSERVE I SURE
THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT TO
START OUT BY SAYING THANK YOU
TO I CHEER CHIU FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE IS
WELL AS AT THE COMMITTEE STAFF
THEY HAVE ALWAYS BEEN SINCERE
IN THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WHICH I WILL WALK
THROUGH MOMENTARILY. THAT I
DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU THAT
WERE LIVING IN I'M PRESIDENT
TIMES WITH WILDFIRES HERE IN
THE GOLDEN STATE THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF WILDFIRES IN THE STATE
THEY'VE CHANGED THEIR LARGER
THEY'RE MORE DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLY ARE NOW MORE THAN ANY
OTHER TIME IN MODERN HISTORY
NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE WEST COAST THE
NEW NORMALS HEARING HONESTLY
THAT'S WHY WE NEED SB TWELVE WE
KNOW THE TRADITIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES IN HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS MUST CHANGE.
WHAT IS ALWAYS WORK LIKE SIMPLY
RELYING ON BUILDING MATERIALS
TO WITHSTAND WILDFIRE NO LONGER
WORKS IN THIS ERA OF MEGA FIRES
THIS IS WHAT OUR NEW NORMAL
LOOKS LIKE TWENTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN HOMEOWNER PAYOUTS
AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FIRES
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TWENTY SIX
BILLION INSURANCE PAYOUTS ANY
NORMAL MEANS IN THE LAST SIXTY
YEARS CALIFORNIA WAS BURNING-
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR
BACK IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
TODAY WE'RE NOW BERNIE NEARLY
TWO MILLION EVERY YEAR AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S GOING TO
INCREASE OVER THE NEXT DECADE.
THE NEW NORMAL MEANS ALMOST ALL
THE LAND BERNIE NOW IS IN HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS WHERE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS LIVE
THE NEW NORMAL MEANS THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS INTERVENING WITH
LAWSUITS ON TWO MASSIVE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS IN THE
WILD AND URBAN INTERFACE
BECAUSE AN INADEQUACY OF FIRE
SAFETY REVIEW IN THE THIRD
SEPARATE LAWSUIT FOUND A LARGE
DEVELOPMENT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAD INADEQUATE
WILDFIRE SAFETY ASSESSMENT I
SAY THAT NOT THROWING STONES
BUT JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
FACTS THAT ARE AT HAND. THE
EVIDENCE IS IN OUR KERR JOINT
PERMITTING PROCESS. IN THIS ERA
ARE STARTING TO PUT RESIDENTS
IN HARM'S WAY. BUT ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING NEW RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS IN HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES WERE EVEN
INCENTIVIZING NEW DEVELOPMENTS
IN AREAS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BURNED. INTO WHAT WE BELIEVE IS
THAT THIS BILL ACTS RATIONALLY.
WE ALREADY IMPLEMENT SAFETY
STANDARDS WHERE WE BUILD WHEN
IT COMES TO HIGH FLOOD RISK
ZONES. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
BUILDING STANDARDS ON
EARTHQUAKE ZONES IN YOUR FAULT
LINES. IN RECENT YEARS
WILDFIRES HAVE KILLED MORE
CALIFORNIANS THAN EARTHQUAKES
AND FLOODS COMBINED AND THE
RISK CONTINUES TO MULTIPLY YEAR
AFTER YEAR. SB TWELVE IS PART
OF THE BLUEPRINT FOR FIRE SAFE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
WHICH WOULD ENSURE CITIES AND
COUNTIES CREEK FIRE SAFETY
STANDARDS PRIOR TO PERMITTING
DEVELOPMENT IN VERY HIGH RISK
AREAS IT'S A BALANCING
REASONABLE LEGISLATIVE RESPONSE
TO THE WILDFIRE EMERGENCY THAT
IS ENGULFING IN ENDANGERING OUR
COMMUNITIES. UNLIKE WHAT SOME
MEMBERS HAVE SAID OR LIKE THE
LA TIMES EDITORIAL BOARD THIS
IS NOT AN OUTRIGHT MORATORIUM.
SB TWELVE CENTS A MINIMUM FOR
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE HIGHEST
FIRE RISK AREAS IN CALIFORNIA.
ONLY IN THE HIGHEST VERY- HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONES SO THERE'VE
BEEN SOME CONFUSION THAT THIS
WOULD TAKE IN MORE BUT IT'S AN
ONLY THE HIGHEST FIRE RISK
ZONE. CURRENT STATE STANDARDS
ARE LIMITED TO THE BUILDING
CODE AND REQUIREMENTS FOR ROAD
SIGNS IN FUEL BRICKS SB TWELVE
SETS UP A TRANSFORMATIONAL
PROCESS FOR THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL TO ESTABLISH BOLD NEW
STANDARDS THAT ENSURE
DEVELOPMENTS AS A WHOLE ARE
DESIGNED. TO WITHSTAND FIRE NOT
JUST THE BUILDINGS WITHIN THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS SO WHAT KIND OF
STANDARDS ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
SO NUMBER ONE A WILDFIRE
ASSESSMENT AND WHILE FOR HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN WOULD BE
ESTABLISHED THROUGH THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE. LOCATION
AND CONSTRUCTION OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE IGNITION POTENTIAL AND
AT THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE
AVAILABILITY OF WATER SUPPLIES
ESSENTIAL FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION
DURING A WILDFIRE. THERE WOULD
NOT OF THEIR NO LONGER BE
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
DEVELOPMENT ONE WAY IN AND ONE
WAY OUT YOU'D HAVE TO HAVE
INGRESS AND EGRESS DEFENSIBLE
SPACE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
FUEL MODIFICATION REQUIREMENTS.
AND IN ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED FUNDED AND
IMPLEMENTED TO VERIFY ONGOING
COMPLIANCE IT WOULD BE BACK BY
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION FEES. BUT
WE PUT. THIS LEGISLATION WILL
HELP SAVE LIVES. HOWEVER THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT
STANDARDS BE REASONABLE. AND TO
BE FEASIBLE. AND ACHIEVABLE FOR
THE MAJORITY DEVELOPMENTS. THIS
MEANS DESPITE WHAT SOME HAVE
SAID S. B. TWELVE WILL NOT
CREATE A BLANKET BAN ON NEW
DEVELOPMENT. I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THERE IS A PARALLEL EFFORT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AT THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY. THEY
CANDIDLY TAKES EIGHT MUCH MORE
ROBUST APPROACH WHEN IT COMES
TO BUILDING IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
AREAS. SB TWELVE DOES NOT DO
THAT. THESE STANDARDS WITHIN
THIS BILL ARE TIERED TO THE
STANDARDS GET INCREASINGLY
STRONGER AS DEVELOPMENTS GET
LARGER IN VERY HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS. IT'S STRUCTURED THIS WAY
BECAUSE LARGER DEVELOPMENTS PUT
MORE FOLKS INTO THOSE ZONES
THIS MEANS THAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE STRINGENT BUT-
ARE NOT TOO COSTLY TO PREVENT
DEVELOPMENT. NOW THANKS TO THE
CHAIR IN TWO PREVIOUS CHAIRS
WE'VE AMENDED THIS BILL AT
SINCE THE LAST COMMITTEE TO
CLARIFY THAT THE WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS ONLY APPLY
TO RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS.
NOT TO RETAIL NOT COMMERCIAL
EXCEPT. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
HEARD THAT SECTION SEVENTEEN OF
THIS BILL COULD IMPACT THE
BORDER FORCE REACH REGULATORY
AUTHORITY. AT WHICH WAS NOT OUR
INTENTION TO ADDRESS THIS
CONCERN WE'VE AMENDED THE BILL
TO REMOVE THE LINE FROM THE
PERIMETER. WE ALSO WORK CLOSELY
WITH AT THE COMMITTEES
EXCELLENT- WELL I'M A
CONSULTANT TO CREATE THE
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS WHICH I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO OVER.
CLARIFY THAT THE FINDINGS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WAS MAKE TO APPROVE
MINUTES PROJECT ARE NOT SEPTIC
SEQUEL. NUMBER TWO LIMON
OFFSITE IMPROVEMENTS FOR A
SINGLE RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT
AND WE CLARIFY TECHNICAL-
CHANGES RELATED TO FIRE
SUBDIVISION MAPS. AND THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY REGULATIONS. THIS
ISTHE THIRD YEAR OF THIS BILL.
THIRD YEAR OF THIS BILL IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. SINCE THIS BILL.
WAS ORIGINALLY INTRODUCED WE'VE
HAD DOZENS OF CALIFORNIANS
STUFF. TWENTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL LOSSES IN THE SAME
ZONES THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ADVANCING STANDARDS FOR. TOO
MANY TIMES IN THE PAST SO JUST
BE HONEST. TOO MANY TIMES IN
THE PAST POLITICS HAVE GOTTEN
THE WAY OF DATA. THE DATA SHOWS
THAT WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE WAY
WE BUILD IN THE WAY WE REBUILD
IN CALIFORNIA. IF WE DON'T
CANDIDLY WE NO MORE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION WILL FOLLOW. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY AND YOU HAVE MY ASSURANCE
MISTER CHAIRMAN DEVICE YOU'RE
TO THE MEMBERS. THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE. ON THIS
BILL AND IF THERE ARE AREAS
WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE THIS BILL.
WILL SINCERELY DO SO SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT WITH LAUREN DAVE
WINFIELD ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND ERIN
REID SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS. LOCAL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE- PLEASE I'M SO
SORRY. CENTER STERN A POLICE
THEY'RE STERN ALSO- IT WHO IS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
HI MISTER CHAIR IS ALSO HERE I
APOLOGIZE SENATOR. APOLOGIES
FOR THE- APOLOGIES FOR GETTING
A YEARLY WITNESS HOPEFULLY- I
WON'T BELABOR THE POINT AT
MISTER CHAIR JUST APPRECIATE
YOU TAKING A MOMENT ALL I WOULD
SAY MEMBERS IS THAT I'M THE ONE
WITH THE MARCH MORE AGGRESSIVE
VERSION OF THIS LEGISLATION
THAT WAS HELD IN THE SENATE- SB
FIFTY FIVE- WE PUT FORWARD IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE AN
ACTUAL BAR ON CERTAIN
DEVELOPMENTS- IF CERTAIN
CONDITIONS WERE MET. AND I'M
I'M- I'M A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE BUT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT EVEN AS IT'S BEEN AMENDED
TODAY- PASSING WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY EQUIVALENT OF SB
ONE EIGHTY TWO THAT PASSED WITH
NEAR UNANIMOUS SUPPORT- COUPLE
YEARS AGO. I JUST HOPE THIS
LEGISLATURE REALIZES THAT WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO GO BACKWARDS I
THINK THIS IS PRESERVING WHAT.
THE GOVERNOR I WAS SITTING ON
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK A COUPLE
YEARS AGO- AND PUTS A MINIMUM
STANDARDS IN PLACE. BUT THE
FACT IS IT'S INEQUITABLE. TO
ALLOW THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
VERY HIGH END PROPERTIES IN
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES
IN MY VIEW AND HAVE THAT BE
SUBSIDIZED BY EVERYBODY ELSE
THE CROSS SUBSIDY OF ALLOWING
THE NEXT MILLION CALIFORNIANS
TO MOVE INTO VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES ON EVERYBODY
ELSE IS OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
UNDER REASON STANFORD ANALYSIS
AND THAT KIND OF SORT OF CROSS
TRANSFER IS SOMETHING THAT WE
DON'T ALWAYS APPRECIATE BUT IF
THERE'S ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
ENSURE THOSE DEVELOPMENTS ARE
AS- DURABLE AND SUSTAINABLE AS
POSSIBLE AND WE'RE SEEING IT
HAPPEN. OUT IN NEW HALL RANCH
THEY'RE DOING THAT WORK THEY
CLEARED THEIR SEQUEL PROCESS
AND ARE BUILDING A DEVELOPMENT
WITH PROPER HARDENING STANDARDS
IN PLACE THAT'S THE KIND OF
DEVELOPMENT THAT CAN MAKE IT
THROUGH- UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK I
HAVE A MUCH MORE STRINGENT
ATTITUDE ABOUT THESE THINGS BUT
I WANT TO PUT THAT IN CONTEXT
THAT I THINK THAT CENTER
REQUIRE A PLUG HIS DIPLOMACY IN
THIS EFFORT AND I KNOW THESE
ARE VERY TRICKY POLITICS AND
THESE ARE HIGH STAKES RIGHT.
THERE'S LITIGATION UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW AND THE CUT THERE'S A
LOT OF SENSITIVITY THAT PENDING
REGULATIONS BUT I WOULD JUST
SAY I THINK THIS MEASURES A
MODEST STEP FORWARD I THINK
IT'S MUCH MORE WORK TO BE DONE
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU LETTING
ME- WAY IN A LITTLE BIT OF
SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN THROUGH
SEVENTEEN FIRES IN THEIR
DISTRICTS SINCE I CAME INTO
OFFICE LOS MY OWN PLACE AND TO
GO HOME TO PLACES LIKE MALAGA
IN CALABASAS AND SAY YOU GUYS
HAVE TO DO BETTER. THAT'S THE
REALLY HARD WORK IS TO GO HOME
INTO THESE ZONES AND SAY- WE
CAN ALL DO BETTER SO I HOPE-YOU'LL CONSIDER SUPPORTING DAY
THANKS FOR LET ME TAKE A MOMENT
THANK YOU CENTER LET'S NOT GO
TO THE MAIN WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE- FROM THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND CAL
FIRE- TO THE OPERATOR. THEIR
LIVES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AREN'T
ABLE ONE PAIR REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
VERY PLEASED TO BE PART OF SB
TWELVE WHICH MAKES A NUMBER OF
VERY IMPORTANT CHANGES
REGARDING PLANNING FOR AND
PERMITTING DEVELOPMENT AND VERY
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS. PLANNING
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENCY
HAS BEEN TOP OF MIND IN THE
PLANNING PROFESSION WILDFIRES
ARE SERIOUS ISSUES FACING
DEVELOPMENTS AND IT'S BECOME
CLEAR THAT BOLD NEW STUFF LIKE
THOSE NOT THE TWELVE NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN TO BETTER PREPARE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND MORE RESILIENT
WAY. POSSIBLY AS SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND BETTER STERN HAS
SAID WE ARE ALREADY FACING
ANOTHER VERY CHALLENGING
WILDFIRE SEASON- AND
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF RECORD
DRY CONDITIONS EVEN AS WE SPEAK
FIRES ARE LITERALLY BURNING
THREE COMMUNITY IN RIGHT NOW.
AND MAJOR MEDIA OUTLETS HAVE
REPEATEDLY HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED
TO PREPARE AND RETHINK HOW WE
DEVELOP IN THESE AREAS THERE'S
A NEW THIS MEANS RECAPPING HOW
LAND USE PLANNING HAS BEEN DONE
IN HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS
IDENTIFYING AND MITIGATING
EXISTING RUN OVER TO MY PHONE
NUMBER. OF ALL THE ROLE
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTING
STRONGER BUILDING STANDARDS
COORDINATING WITH STATE
AGENCIES AND ENSURING THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
SUPPORTED WITH GUIDANCE AND
FUNDING TO MAKE IT CRITICAL
CHANGES THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT SB
TWELVE MOBILE WHAT THE BILL
WILL NOT DO IS BANNED ABOUT
MEANT. IT SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT
BEFORE DOING SO IMPORTANT FIRE
SAFETY STANDARDS NEED TO BE MET
TO ENSURE ADEQUATE PROTECTION
CAN BE PROVIDED THE BILL
REQUIRED PLANNING UPDATES TO
THE SAFETY AND LAND USE ELEMENT
ALONG WITH WILDFIRE REDUCTION
STANDARDS WILL ENSURE EXISTING
HOME TO HARDEN NEW DEVELOPMENTS
ARE THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDERED AND
DEVELOPED WITH FEASIBLE
STANDARDS THAT MUST BE MET TO
PROTECT NOT JUST PROPERTY BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY PEOPLE'S
LIVES. AND WE ARE FACING
MOUNTING RISK FROM WILDFIRES IN
COMMUNITIES WE ARE ALSO FACING
OBVIOUSLY A HOUSING CRISIS AND
WE BELIEVE SB TOLD THE COURT
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING PRIORITIES
BY ENCOURAGING MORE SUSTAINABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES
AND APPROPRIATELY DESIGNING.
COMMUNITIES AND VERY HIGH FIRE
RISK. ALL OF THIS MORNING THE
STATE HOUSING PRODUCTION. FOR
EACH THREE JOIN THAT NEEDS OF
THE- DOES NOT KEEP HOUSING FOR
BEING THE- COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT HOW. BETTER PLANNING
AND STANDARDS HAND HOW REDUCE
ALL MOBILE OF NEED TO. APA
CALIFORNIA PRE ALL UPPER. OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE SENATOR STERN
AS WELL AS THE LARGEST. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON WELFARE
MITIGATION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE MY VOTE THANK YOU. THREE
MISTER REED ON. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALLEN READ
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE- FIRST ONE I
THINK THE COMMITTEE- FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BUT- ALSO
IMPORTANT AT SEVEN ACQUIRING
TENER STERN HAVE BEEN CHAMPIONS
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AND FOR THE
SAFETY OF FIREFIGHTERS- AND WE
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR
EFFORTS IN THIS BILL- THERE'S
MORE MORE PEOPLE MOVING INTO
WHAT WE CALL THE WILD URBAN
INTERFACE. A CALLED LOUIS ALL
THE TIME AND IT MAKES IT MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT FIGHTING FIRES
WHEN THEY'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
TO PROTECT LIVES AND HOMES AND-
SO SOMETIMES IT'S A IT'S A
DISTRACTION PARTICULAR HOMES
ARE NOT WELL BILL THEY'RE NOT
FIRE RETARDANT- MATERIALS AND
SO PLANNING IS IMPORTANT. AND.
I THINK THAT BUT- FOR THE NEXT
TWELVE IS SENSE BUT- IT SHOULD
DONE A LONG TIME AGO- BUT HE
NEARLY 25% OF OUR POPULATION IS
IN THE LOUIS NOW. AND SO THAT'S
A HUGE HUGE ISSUE FOR CAL FIRE
AND I THINK CHOIR MENTIONED.
MOST OF THE MOST SERIOUS FIRES
IN OUR STATE HISTORY HAVE
OCCURRED IN JUST THE LAST TEN
YEARS- THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF HOMES HAVE BEEN LOST.
HUNDREDS OF LIVES HAVE BEEN
LOST. FIREFIGHTERS THE BLACK
DEVILS IN THEIR LIVES AS WELL.
AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL WILL
HELP PROTECT EVERYBODY AND IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
THAT- I'VE. I HAVE NEVER SEEN
IT. THAT I GO OUT TO PARIS
EVERY YEAR AND- I'VE NEVER SEEN
IT I THOUGHT LAST YEAR WAS BAD
AND I'M AFRAID THIS YEAR MAY BE
WORSE. LAST YEAR- WE LOST OVER
FOUR MILLION ACRES AND FORCED
LOTS OF LICENSE AND- HOMES. SO
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I WANT TO CLOSE ON ONE
THING OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE
WORKING TWENTY EIGHT DAYS
STRAIGHT WITHOUT A DAY OFF.
THEY GET ONE DAY OFF AND THEY
HAVE TO GO BACK ON THE FIRE
AGAIN FOR ANOTHER MONTH- IT'S-
TERRIBLE CONDITIONS BUT WE'VE
GOT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO
REDUCE OUR FIRE EXPOSURES SB
TWELVE IS JUST ONE STEP AND I
KNOW MCGUIRE IS WORKING ON MANY
OTHER ISSUES AS WELL INCLUDING
ADDING MRE FIREFIGHTERS. SO I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR IT
LETTING ME TEXT BY THIS MORNING
THANK. YOU FOR THIS AFTERNOON
NOW. AT THIS TIME WHEN WE GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL- SMI SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM SCENE NOT- LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS. SEEN
ON LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OF MADAME OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE ALLOW MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND WE ASK THAT YOU ONLY
STATE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT TO
SUPPORT SO- MIKE MCGUIRE.
SENATOR SUPPORT. TO THE
OPERATOR. Q. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ABOUT
TWO COMMON THINK YOU WILL GO TO
Y. NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
A JURY MEMBERS NOT A MEMO AND
CALLING IN SUPPORT IN THE HOUSE
OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT BECAUSE PATIENTS-
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BYE NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS OF ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ROGER DICKINSON OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
LET'S NOW GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I KNOW THERE ARE TWO
I THINK WE HAVE ONE HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE ROOM- SILVIA
FERRARI AND THEN WE WILL GO TO
Y. ELLIE KENDRICK FROM THE
REALTORS WHO WILL BE ON THE
PHONES. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AT SILVIO FOR OUR IN
BEHALF THE CAIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION-
UNFORTUNATELY CONTINI BE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO A BILL THAT.
CONTINUES TO BE DESIGNATED AS A
HOUSING KILLER- I'M JUST GOING
TO FOCUS MY FEW MINUTES ON.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED IN THIS
BILL- I DON'T THINK THAT CENTER
ACTUALLY GOT TO EXPLAIN IT BUT
THERE ARE SOME AMENDMENTS TO
DEAL WITH SEE WHAT. OUR VIEWERS
ARE VERY LIMITED- SEQUIN
MAINTENANCE AND THEY ONLY DEAL
WITH HALF THE ISSUE. THOSE
SEQUEL AMENDMENTS ARE SPECIFIC
TO IF I WALK AND ACTUALLY
PHYSICALLY PULL A PERMIT. THAT
THAT ACTION DOES NOT TRIGGER
SEQUEL AND IT MAINTAINS. ITS
MINISTERIAL APPLICATION. NUMBER
TWO WHAT IS REALLY PROBLEMATIC
ABOUT THE SEQUEL PROVISION AND
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE C. QUIT
CALLING. IT IS THAT THERE NEEDS
TO BE WHAT WE CALL
GRANDFATHERED. THERE NEEDS TO
BE A CLEAR CUT MOMENT IN TIME
WHERE ONCE YOU HIT THIS POINT.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE ASKED.
OR HAVE THE GOAL POSTS MOVED ON
YOU. THERE ARE INSTANCES IN
VIRTUALLY EVERY PROJECT WHERE
YOU GO OUT TO THE FIELD AND
THERE ARE MINOR MODIFICATIONS.
CHANGES TO THE PROJECT THAT ARE
BASED ON REAL WORLD
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN YOUR OUT
THERE IT COULD BE MOVING TO
CURB CUT SIX INCHES CHANGING A
ROADS LIGHTLY. READJUSTING WHAT
COULD BE A RADII FOR- IN
IMPROVE TRAFFIC FLOW WHATEVER
IT IS. THOSE ARE MINOR
MODIFICATIONS IN CONTEXT THE
WHOLE PROJECT. THOSE THOSE
MINOR CHANGES SHOULD NOT. RE
TRIGGER NEW FIRE STANDARD WHICH
RE TRIGGER SEQUEL. WE CANNOT
HAVE A SO WE HAVE NOT DEALT
WITH THE SEQUEL- IN REGARDS TO
THE AMENDMENT THAT'S BEEN
PROPOSE WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
BOTH SIDES OF THE COIN. ALSO
YEAH YOU HEARD IT REFERENCED-
IN PRESENTATION. BUT THERE IS
THERE IS LANGUAGE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES REQUIREMENTS
AUTHORIZES A REQUIREMENT TO BE
IN FEASIBLE UNACHIEVABLE. AND
ON- UNREASONABLE IN FEASIBLE
AND ACHIEVABLE THERE. GOT IT.
HOWEVER THAT IT IS THAT IS 49%
OF PROJECTS POTENTIALLY UP
2409% A PROJECT WHEN YOU LOOK
AT EVEN OUR STATE'S CLIMATE
REGIME. SB THREE SEVEN FIVE
WHAT WE USE THEIR- AMBITIOUS
BUT ACHIEVABLE. EVEN IN THAT
CONTEXT WE RECOGNIZE IT HAS TO
BE ACHIEVABLE IN THE STATE OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
TODAY. THE FACT WE'RE GONNA
STATUTORILY AUTHORIZED UP 2409%
OF PROJECTS TO BE UNREASONABLE
WE SHOULD NOT BE GOING THERE
THAT SHOULD NOT BE ACCEPTABLE.
AND LASTLY THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH THIS INITIAL
I POPPED UP- HARPED ON ALL YEAR
LONG. BUT THE FACT THAT THE OPR
CAN. BIG FOOT THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL IN THIS BILL THE WAIT
IS CURRENTLY DRAFTED. WE HAVE
THOUGHT THAT THAT HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE ALL SORT
OF UNDERSTOOD WOULD BE DEALT
WITH IT HASN'T BEEN YET HE
NEEDS TO BE. AN TO THE
ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE OF THIS BILL
THAT PLAY INTO THIS BILL. BOARD
OF FORESTRY STATE FIRE MARSHAL
CAL FIGHTER. EVERY ONE OF THOSE
AGENCIES IS OPERATING.
REGULATORY PACKAGES UPDATING
WILDFIRE MAPS BUILDING
STANDARDS EVERYONE OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES PLAYS INTO THIS
BILL. THOSE ISSUES ARE GOING TO
BE SETTLED LATE THIS YEAR
LIKELY NOVEMBER. THAT SHOULD BE
THE POINT IN TIME WHEN WE TAKE
A STEP BACK LOOK AT ALL THOSE
CHANGES AND SAY. NOW WHAT
REALLY IS IN PLAY IN THIS BILL
BUT AS THE SENATOR SAID.
THERE'S A CHANCE THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY. FOR ONCE IS ALSO
COULD BE MORE AGGRESSIVE COULD
BE ARE GOING OFF IN A DIFFERENT
WAY WE DON'T KNOW YET. BUT IF
THAT'S THE CASE THEN THERE'S NO
NEED FOR THIS BILL. SO THIS IS
NOT READY THERE ARE A LOT OF
CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE MADE.
IT NEEDS TO BE A TO YOUR BILL
WE WOULD URGE A NO VOTE. LET'S
NOT GO TO THE PHONES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KELLY GOT BURKE AND I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. TODAY RESPECTFULLY
AND CONTINUED OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE. ADDED BEEN DISCUSSED
THERE BEEN MANY CONCERNS RAISED
ABOUT HOW SB TWELVE WILL PUT
SWEEPING NEW RESTRICTIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS ON SOME OF THE
ONLY AREAS LEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE OPEN TO AFFORDABLY
ACCOMMODATING GROWTH. THE
AMENDMENTS BEING PROPOSED AT
THIS TIME SO DO NOT ADDRESS ALL
OF OUR CONCERNS ABOUT HOW SB
TWELVE FURTHER LIMIT ACCESS TO
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
NOT IN OPPOSITION TO FIRE STATE
COMMUNITY. WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO FIRE MINDED LAND
USE PLANNING AND WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO PUBLIC SAFETY WE
DEEPLY UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES. AND HAZARDS OF
LIVING IN VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES AND WE RESPECT
THE INTENT OF SB TWELVE
HOWEVER. WE ARE STILL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL ECHOING.
THE CONCERNS DICTATED BY THE B.
I. A. THIS LINK BILL AND A
THREE. ISSUE AT THEIR- THAN
JUST PASSING CONSIDERATION. IT
WOULD BE UNFORTUNATE FOR ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECES OF
HOUSING LEGISLATION BROUGHT
FORTH THIS YEAR. TO MOVE OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE WE CAN
REACH AN AGREEMENT ON HOW TO
CONTINUE TO SAFELY PROVIDE. A
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING THAT
CALIFORNIANS WITH THEIR- AND
WITH THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU. THIS
TIME LET'S GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO STATE THE
FACT OF THEIR OPPOSITION.
ANYONE HERE IN THIS CHAMBER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRIS CONNOR
PRESENT IN THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. AND IN THE WROTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. AND NOW
GOING TO THE PHONE LINES TO THE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE TO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN
Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OH
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
COMMITTEE ADAM RIGHTLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ONE ECHO- THE COMIC THE CDA AND
REALTORS WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DIANA BARNATO WITH THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES CENTER AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
NINETY FIVE PLEASE FOR I HAD.
YEAH CAN YOU REMEMBER PERSONAL
CHAOS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GERMAN TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LEAPING CUENTA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RYAN
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
KATHY LYNCH REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN WHAT COUNSEL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DONNA DUPONT CHAIRMAN
OF THE BOARD LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION IS BAD IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS THANK YOU STEVE LAMONT
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF ORANGE COUNTY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAVID TO MY HOUSE HE HOME
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION OF KERN
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT YOU SHARE MEMBER CHRIS
WILL OPEN WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THEY'RE A LITTLE
WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT EIGHTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MATTHEW ADAMS CALLING FROM THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR. THANK YOU
INTERESTS THEY ONE MOMENT SIR
NEXT COMMENT. RIGHT ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
TWO SEVEN. I NEED YOU TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DAVE BUTLER ON BEHALF
OF UNITED CHAMBER ADVOCACY
NETWORK COALITION OF SEVEN
LOCAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE HERE
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE NINETEEN. THIS IS CHRIS
COLLIER WITH THE GOOD OF THE
CHILD ON THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING
ON TOP OF THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED- POSITION WITH
ITEMS THREE AND FOUR OF TEIR
LETTER REMAINING ON A DRAFT
THANK YOU FOR THE AMENDMENTS SO
FAR. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN PALMER
WROTE THAT JENNA BARBARA COUNTY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
OF THE COMMITTEE MCCARTY
MEDINA- WITH ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
DATE BARTLETT BROOKFIELD
RESIDENTIAL AND CHAIRMAN OF THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS ROBERT COOPER DR
APPOINT ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
HUNDRED AND UNITED LATINOS VOTE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I DON'T WANT TO WAIT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ADAM WOULD WITH THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF RIVERSIDE OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AROUND ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN BERMAN
WITH GROUP YOU'LL RESIDENTIAL
AND CHAIR OF THE EARTH
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ARE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SAID MASTERSON QUESTIONER
PAYMENT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU RYAN FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR THREE. ONE ONE
OF SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
DON HOLD FIRM WITH SHEA HOMES
WE BUILD IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SAN DIEGO THE BAY AREA IN THE
CENTRAL COAST WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU BYE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT NINE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MIKE BALSAMO REPRESENTING
MASTER PLAN DEVELOPER RANCHO
MISSION VIEJO WE DO BUSINESS IN
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY YOUR
OPPOSED SB TWELVE. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN CHIU AN HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
CARLOS RODRIGUEZ EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WITH THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PALM BEACH CHAPTER
WOULD SERVE SALMON DINO COUNTY.
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS PLENTY HATCHER
WITH THE HOME BUILDERS
ASSOCIATION OF THE CENTRAL
COAST SERVING SLOW AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S. B.
TWELVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE ONE ONE SEVEN. RIGHT
ONE OF FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BELIEVE LAMPARAS
VENTURA COUNTY COALITION OF
LABOR AGRICULTURE AND BUSINESS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS LOU MONDALE
ON BEHAF OF THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE COUNTY
CHAPTER IN STRONG OFFICE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AROUND ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BLAMES
BANK TERM ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND A MEMBER OF THE NORTH STATE
PIAA WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB
TWELVE. THANK YOU RYAN THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GORE AT. MY NAME IS
EDUARDO PARET MEMBER- BEEN FOR
STATE THE I. NA IN LANDSCAPE
PROFESSIONAL AND I AM OPPOSED.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LANE MAR SO WE SHAPE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I'M TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JOHN WROTE THAT
WITH EQUITY RESIDENTIAL IN
OPPOSITION ECHOING THE POSITION
OF THE BA AND THE REALTORS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOCUMENTS HERE AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS CORNELIUS
BURKE WITH THE NORTH STATE B. I
REPRESENT THE HOMEBUILDING
INDUSTRY FROM SACRAMENTO OREGON
BORDER WHERE STARSHIP OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSIONS AND
COMMENTS. THE NUMBER COMMENTS
WAS START WITH MS WICKS ARE
ACTUALLY UP MISS COURTS OVER TO
YOU I KNOW YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
RUN THE COMMITTEE SO. CAN WE
START WITH YOU. IN THE MIDDLE
OF- I WANNA KEEP MY- YEAH. I
YES I DO WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
I'M RUNNING BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN COMMITTEES THAT'S WHY
I'M RUNNING OUT OF JAIL HAS THE
SAME SITUATION GOING ON IN THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT I DO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BACK
AS WAS MENTIONED BY NOT ONLY
YOU BUT SENATOR A STERN- THIS
IS SOMETHING YOU'VE BEEN AT
WORK FOR A WILL A QUITE A LONG
TIME I ALSO KNOW THAT- YOU- I.
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
THROUGHOUT THE WEEKEND YOU'VE
TAKEN SOME OF THE ADMIT IT MEN
MINUTES I DO HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS- BUT OF COURSE IN MY
SCOPE SCUFFLE HERE THEY ARE-
ONE IS THE CONCERN THAT WAS
MENTIONED RELATED TO SEQUEL-
AND RELATED TO- IF A PROJECT IS
DOWN THE ROAD AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN THERE CAN BE SOME KIND
OF MOCK MINOR MODIFICATION WITH
THIS IN FACT REQUIRES A WHOLE
NOTHER ROUND A SEQUEL CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MEDICINE NUMBER.
SO WE DO NEED TO HAVE CNTINUE
CONVERSATIONS ON THAT ISSUE THE
EXAMPLE OF A CURB CUT BEING
CHANGE IS NOT WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO GET AFTER RIGHT I THINK THAT
EVEN IF THERE IS A TENTATIVE
MATTER MAP APPROVED THAT A
pFOR OVER A DECADE WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT TRYING TO MESS UP
THAT TENTATIVE MAP THAT HAD
BEEN PREVIOUSLY APPROVED BY A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT I DO THINK
IT IS FAIR TO SAY THAT IF THERE
IS A DEVELOPMENT THAT IS
CURRENTLY. IN DISCUSSION AT A
COUNCIL PLANNING COMMISSION
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS LEVEL-
THAT SHOULD BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS I'M MORE THAN WILLING
MORE THAN WILLING MADAM
ASSEMBLY WOMAN NOW SAY THIS ON
THE RECORD TODAY TO BE ABLE TO
FIND A SWEET SPOT FOR A
COMPROMISE- BUT IT THE EXAMPLE
OF A MINOR CHANGE IN THE
SIDEWALK OR A CURB CUT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD BE
LOOKING AT TRIGGERING A WHOLE
NEW REFERRAL FOR ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS AT THE A SEQUIN
MITIGATION AND WILDFIRE SAFETY.
THANK YOU AND THEN I HAD A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. THIS LAST
FRIEDMAN I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTEND THE C. C. GOLDEN
STATE TOUR AND WE WERE UP IN
THE ROOM FIRE ZONES WE WERE UP
IN. MANY AREAS HAVE HAD QUITE A
BIT OF DAMAGE AND- THERE WERE A
LOT OF DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN
FORESTRY BETWEEN. DEVELOPERS
BETWEEN ALL THE REGULATION-
THAT HAPPENS IN ORDER TO GET A
PROJECT MOVE FORWARD. AND SOME
OF THE CONCERN IS WHAT HAS BEEN
STATED WHICH IS. ON THE ONE
HAND WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH
CALIFORNIA FORWARDING YOU WERE
JUST HERE LAST WEEK WITH-
MOVING SOME BILLS THAT WOULD.
MOVE FORWARD WITH HOUSING. AND
THEN THE OTHER HAND IS THIS
GOING TO ACTUALLY STALL OR-
REDUCE HOUSING UNITS AS THIS IS
NOW- AMENDED. TO JUST SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES. CAN YOU ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THAT ONE OF
YOUR- I THINK AREAS YOU SPEND
TIME IS TRYING TO GET HOUSING
PRODUCTION. I HAD EVER SEEN YES
WE'VE AMENDED THE BILL JUST TO
FOCUS ON RESIDENTIAL SO THAT IS
WHERE WE TO MINUTES- COMMERCIAL
RETAIL EXEDRA. LOOK WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR. SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM TO DAY WERE NEUTRAL ON A
BILL. CANDIDLY WAS STRONGER
LAST YEAR IT RECEIVED A VETO
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED THESE NEW
RAGS DON'T GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL
THE NEXT RENEWAL CYCLE WHICH IS
NINE YEARS ALMOST A DECADE AWAY
THAT WAS- AND ADMIT THAT WE
TOOK NUMBER THREE ON OPR. SO
THROUGH SENATOR WIENER WE TOOK
AN AMENDMENT. TO IN BED OPR
LANGUAGE THAT WAS IN LAST
YEAR'S BILL BASED OFF OF THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN RULES AND
NOT ON NEW RULES THAT WILL BE
ARE STILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DRAFT AND APPROVE. SO THAT WE
AT ELIMINATE ANY SQUISHY NESS
ON WHAT THE POTENTIAL NEW OPR
RATES WOULD BE BECAUSE WE BASE
THEM OFF LAST YEAR WHICH-
CANDIDLY- MANY OF THOSE WHO
OPPOSE TODAY. WERE NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL WITH THE SAME LANGUAGE
LAST YEAR. THE LAST THING I'LL
SAY IN REGARDS TO HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT- I LET MY TRACK
RECORD SPEAK FOR MYSELF- I CO
CHAIRED OUR HOUSING WORKING
GROUP IN THE SENATE. MY WIFE
AND I STRUGGLE TO BE ABLE TO
STAY IN THE HOME AND I GREW UP
IN BUT STAY IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT WE THAT I GREW UP IN. IF
YOU'RE A FORDER HOME. HOUSING
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ISSUES TO ME. AND WHAT I'VE
SEEN. OVER MY TIME THIS
LEGISLATURE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. IT'S FIRE IF THE FIRE.
THOUSANDS OF THOSE WHO I WORK
FOR HAVE LOST THEIR HOME. AND
WE'VE CHEERED THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THE LARGER DEVELOPMENTS.
HAVE MORE MITIGATIONS BUT NO
WE'RE IN THIS BILL DOES IT SAY
THAT HOUSING CAN'T BE BUILT.
BOTTOM LINE. NOW WE HAVE TO DO
ADDITIONAL EGRESS AND INGRESS
AND EGRESS YES WOULD YOU HAVE
TO BUILD A BUILDING H. AWAY
DUES TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
WORK ON- WILDFIRE- MITIGATION
YES BUT IT'S COMMON SENSE AND I
GOT TO BE CANDID MAKE THIS INTO
YOUR BILL THIS BILL HAS BEEN IN
FRONT OF THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT LAST YEAR THAT WAS YEAR
TWO. WE'RE NOW IN YEAR THREE.
SO IF NOT HI I JUST MIGHT MIGHT
MIGHT YOU HEAR A LITTLE BIT OF
MY FRUSTRATION OF. WE'VE TRIED
TO BE ABLE TO A MAN THIS BILL-
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT MORE
PALATABLE WHILE ALSO ACTUALLY
PROTECTING LIVES WHO- FOR FOLKS
WHO LIVE IN A NEW DEVELOPMENT.
NOT TURN BACK OVER TO YOU
SOMETHING THAT. THANK YOU THAT
THAT'S IT. ME AS FOR OTHERS.
THIS WORKS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANKS FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I'VE
APPRECIATED OUR CONVERSATIONS I
KNOW WE ALSO SPOKE THIS WEEKEND
AND- IT'S ALWAYS FUN POLICY
MAKING ON THE WEEKENDS- SO YOU
KNOW I HATE MY DISTRICT I HAD A
OF. A FIRE IN NINETEEN NINETY
ONE AND OAKLAND BERKELEY HILLS
THAT SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER
IT'S- AREAS. UNDER
UNDERSTANDABLE MYSTICAL
SIGNIFICANCE AND IN MY REGION
WE HAD OVER TWENTY HUNDRED
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES DESTROYED.
OVER FOUR HUNDRED APARTMENTS
AND CONDOS DESTROYED TWENTY
FIVE PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES-
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE FAT I
THINK SORT ONE OF THE FIRST
BIGGER SORT OF URBAN- ISSUE
FIRES THAT- WE'RE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- SO I HAVE A LOT OF
SENSITIVITY TO WHAT WE'RE DOING
IN THIS REGION AND- I HEAR
ABOUT THIS. EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
MY DISTRICT AND ESPECIALLY WITH
THE DROUGHT AND WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IT'S A REAL PUBLIC
CONCERN FOR PEOPLE- IN MY
DISTRICT. I'M ALSO A BIG
SUPPORTER OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION- AND I'VE AUTHORED A
LOT OF THE BILLS THAT HAVE MADE
IT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK TO
PROMOTE HOUSING PRODUCTION I'M
IN A BIG BELIEVER IN PRODUCTION
AND KNOW THAT WE NEED WE HAVE
TO BUILD THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS FOR
THE NEEDLE I THINK BETWEEN
THESE TWO ISSUES RIGHT- SO I
DEEPLY APPRECIATE I THINK WHERE
YOU'VE COME AND TALKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION. THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE STILL
HONORING THE TRUE INTENT OF THE
BILL WHICH IS TO PROTECT HUMAN
LIVES IN THIS PROCESS. AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE BEING SMART
ABOUT HOW WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
HOUSING AND SOME OF THESE AREAS
WHILE THE SAME TIME ENSURING
THAT WE CAN BUILD THE HOMES
THAT WE NEED AND IT IS NOT. AN
EASY TASK- SO I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'VE DONE SO FAR WITH THIS
BILL. I WOULD ALSO ASK THAT-
YOU CONTINUE TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND WORK THROUGH
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS- AND
HEAR THEM OUT- IT IS MY HOPE
THAT AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
THROUGH YOU KNOW PREPARATIONS
VEGAS OUR COMMUNITY THROUGH
PREPARATIONS A THROUGH THE
FLOOR THE SOMEBODY THAT. YOU
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION SO THAT WOULD BE
AN ASK OF MINE THAT THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION. SENATOR AYE AYE
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- BOTH YOU
AND MISS QUICK SILVA HAVE BEEN
VERY FOCUSED AND- SHE'S A
HOUSING I JUST WANNA SAY THANK
YOU TO BOTH YOU. YOU HAVE MY
WORD. I WOULD LOVE TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW TO BE ABLE TO
FIND THAT SWEET SPOT AS I SAID
ON THIS ISSUE I SEE WHAT- I
THINK THAT THERE IS A MIDDLE
GROUND- ON THIS- AND I'D LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE AGAIN.
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN FIGURING
OUT. HOW TO BE ABLE TO KICK
BACK I COULD. ON CUTS MINOR I.
LIKE THE- I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
BIGGER PICTURE THOUGH OF. IF
IT'S IN PROCESS IF IT'S ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED. AND WHERE IS
THAT POINT. AND THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO WORK
THROUGH AND- YOU HAVE MY WORD
AND- AT. SOME NUMBER. QUICK
SILVA. YEAH MY WORD THAT. WANT
TO TRY TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE
AND- HAVE SINCE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. WILL DO SO. I
APPRECIATE THAT NOW WITH THE
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIMILAR. TO MOTION WITH THE
BILLS ARE SECOND. YOUR SECOND I
MISTER CARR. TO A QUESTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I.
APPLAUD YOU FOR YOUR- PASSION
ABOUT THIS FIRE ISSUE THAT HAS
PLAGUED THE STATE NOT FOR SIX
YEARS BUT FOR PROBABLY THIRTY
NOW- THOSE LARGE FIRES THAT
TIME MISS WHICH IS TALKING
ABOUT HAVE BEEN GOING ON. SINCE
MEMBER GETTING OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL- WATCHING MALIBU.
CALABASAS. ALL THOSE TO PAYING
A CANYON FIRES. AGING THROUGH
THERE AND EVERY FIRE WE LEARNED
SOMETHING ELSE. AND THOSE
THINGS GET CODIFIED INTO THE
UNIFORMBUILDING STANDARDS AND
ALSO THE UNIFORM FIRE CODE.
TODAY'S COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
BEING BUILT LIKE IN AREAS LIKE
WHERE I AM AT. THE SOUTHWEST
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WON THE FASTER
GROWING AREAS IN THE STATE-
HELLO A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS ALREADY BEING
DONE- THERE ALREADY REQUIRING
SPRINKLERS IN THOSE AREAS
FRANKLIN HOMES WHICH ADDS QUITE
A BIT TO COST TO A HOUSE.
THEY'RE ALREADY DOING THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ARE ONLY TO BE
HAMPERED BY SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND LAWS IN THE-
MITIGATION FOR HABITAT AND
CONSERVATION AREAS- GIVEN THAT
THERE ARE THOSE EXTERNAL
PRESSURES YEAH. HOW DO WE HOW
DO YOU GET A- RESIDENTIAL TRACT
OF. PASSED THE HEAD OF THE
LAWSUIT BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD BRING IN ANY IN ANY AREA
LIKE WHERE I AM FROM. THAT
WOULD BE THE WAY TO A KILLER A
RESIDENTIAL THING AND YOU SAID
IT YOURSELF YOU'VE GOT ONE TWO
THREE DIFFERENT RESIDENTIAL
LARGE RESIDENTIAL. PROJECTS
BEING HELD UP IN COURT. BY
LAWSUITS AND I DOUBT THAT THOSE
LAWSUIT TO RUN BY THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT. I PROBABLY BOUGHT
MY PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT THOSE
RESIDENTIAL AREAS IN THOSE TYPE
OF AREAS THAT THEY LEFT. AND I
WOULD SAY THAT EVERY PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IS A IS
PRONE TO FIRE AND THAT'S A
CALIFORNIA IS- WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE ALSO LEARNED IS THAT WE
DON'T PROVIDE ENOUGH HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE THEY WIND UP IN THE
STREET. AND IF WE'RE NOT GOING
TO ALLOW THE OUTER BANDS TO BE-
DEVELOPED. AND WHILE THESE ARE
BEING ADDRESSED ALREADY. THEN
THAT JUST PUSHES THE
DEVELOPMENT BACK INTO AREAS
THAT ARE ALREADY DEVELOPED. AND
IN THOSE AREAS WHERE PEOPLE
DON'T WANT DEVELOPMENT WILL BE
PRESERVED FOREVER- BY- BY OUR
CAMPS- TO SOLVE ISSUES LIKE
THIS- EVERY AREA EVERY REGION
HAS THEIR OWN DIFFERENT FIRE
PROBLEM. AND IN THOSE FIRE
AGENCIES THAT TAKE CARE OF
THOSE AREAS A COUNTIES THE
CITIES AND THE FIRE AGENCIES
ALL HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THEIR SPECIFIC NEEDS
AND THEIR SPECIFIC AREAS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS A MUCH
DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT PROBLEM
THAN THEY HAVE UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. OR THE BAY AREA OR
THE COASTAL REGIONS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT PERCENT
THEY ARE THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
HUMIDITY RATES THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT BURNING RATES THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT TYPES CHAPARRAL-
AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO NEED
TO PUT TOGETHER THE PLAN. D.
FOR THEIR AREA AND THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING IT. SO I'M NOT
SEEING WHAT THIS IS NEEDED FOR.
IN TERMS OF INVENTING THAT- A
LOT OF THE BURNS THAT YOU'VE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT AND- THAT
WE HAVE BEEN. TALKING ABOUT ALL
OF US- THOSE CONFIGURATIONS OF
HAPPEN IN COMMUNITIES OF MEN
BILL LONG AGO. AND THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE STANDARDS AND THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE TWO WAYS OUT-
EVERY DEVELOPMENT I KNOW HAS
ALL THOSE STANDARDS AND THEN
SOME THEY HAVE BOXED EAVES.
THEY ARE DEFENSIBLE SPACE THEY
HAVE ALL THE HOME HARDENING-
ELEMENTS OF A NEED BUT IF YOU
HAVE ONE. BIG STANDARD FOR ALL
OF IT THAT MEANS SOME AREAS
THAT DON'T NEED SOME OF THOSE
TYPE OF HOME HARDENING EFFORTS.
WILL BE LEFT OUT. THERE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE MADE TO. TO TRY TO
TRY TO ADHERE TO THOSE WHEN
THEY DON'T NEED IT WHICH MAKES
THAT HOUSING MORE EXPENSIVE
WHICH PRICES MORE PEOPLE OUT OF
IT. SO YOU KNOW I JUST SEE THIS
THIS. REAL PROBLEM WITH
CONFLICTING- CONFLICTING GOALS.
AND AND THAT'S MY CONCERN WITH
THIS BILL IS A IS HI I SEE FROM
MY END AND BEING THIRTY FIVE
YEARS IN THAT FIRE SERVICE THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN WHAT THEY
DEVELOP NOW VERSUS WHAT THEY
USED TO DEVELOP. AND IN THERE
ARE SOME PLACES THAT THEY DON'T
WANT DEVELOPMENT UNLESS IT'S
JUST THEIR HOUSE AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT AREAS LIKE MALIBU-
THEY HAD TWO YEARS AGO THE FIRE
THAT WENT FROM THOUSAND OAKS
ALL THE WAY TO THE BEACH. AND I
KNEW IT WAS GOING TO GO TO THE
BEACH AS SOON AS IT CAUGHT FIRE
MALAM BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
WIND WAS BLOWING IT WAS STRONG
ENOUGH. THE NEW WITHOUT BRUSHES
LIKE. THERE'S NO STOPPING IT.
SO WHAT ARE WE GONNA TELL THOSE
FOLKS YOU CAN BUILD THEIR
HOUSES ON THEIR LAND ANYMORE.
NO THAT'S IT THAT'S A RISK THEY
TAKE. WHEN THEY BUILD THEIR
HOUSES. IN THE MIDDLE OF A BUT
WHEN SHE TO CHIMNEY BASICALLY.
SO YOU KNOW I JUST FEEL LIKE
WE'RE MAKING TOO BIG OF AN
IMPACT ON ON OUR EFFORTS TO
BUILD HOUSING. AND INCREASE OUR
SUPPLIES SO MORE PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY AFFORD THOSE HOUSES.
SO YOU KNOW THOSE ARE MY
CONCERNS WITH THIS AND- I AM
THANK YOU KNOW I'M I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE OF THIS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER VICE CHAIR TO
CHAIR OF SORRY TO RESPOND.
THANK YOU- NUMBER ONE THIS BILL
IS ONLY FOCUS ON VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD ZONES IT'S NOT FOCUS
ANYWHERE ELSE. WHETHER YOU ARE
LIVING IN THE CHAPARRAL OR LIVE
IN- UP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHERE YOU ARE IN OAKWOOD LANE-
WE HAVE THE MAPS WITH THE VERY
HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES AND SO
IT WOULDN'T ENCOMPASS-
EVERYONE- BUT IN THOSE SAME
ZONES. YOU DO NEED STANDARD
PROTECTION AND NOT EVERY COUNTY
CANDIDLY HAS A MITIGATION PLAN
IN PLACE FOR INSURERS THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING WITHIN
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT THAT IS NOT
A UNIVERSAL PRACTICE IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. NUMBER
TWO- THERE'S A REASON WHY I'M A
CO AUTHOR- IN CHAMPION OF OUR
AB NINE HUNDRED EXTENSION THAT
THE ASSEMBLY IN A BIPARTISAN
VOTE SENATE PASSED THIS YEAR
WHICH IS. A CENTER ATKINS BILL
IT REDUCES. HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT- SEQUEL LAWSUITS
TWO TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAYS. HE GUARANTEES INSURANCE
ANY DAY JUDICIAL REVIEW THERE'S
A REASON WHY I'M SUPPORTING SB
SEVEN- IN A BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
THAT AND THAT IS- TRANSFORMING
DI<c.cyan> DYING MALLS. OFFICE</c>
PARKS- IN STRIP MALLS. TO DO AT
LEAST 50% HOUSING MINISTERIAL
THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT SB NINE TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD QUICKLY-
DUPLEXES IN FOUR PLEXUS. BUT I
GOT TO SAY THE NEW REALITY THAT
WERE IN AND THE REASON WHY THE
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTS THIS. IS BECAUSE THE
STATUS QUO CAN'T CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD WE TALK ABOUT COST
OF THIS BILL WE IGNORE THE COST
OF A TWENTY SIX BILLION DOLLAR
PAY OUT. OF INSURANCE OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS TWENTY SIX
BILLION. BY THE WAY FOR THE
VAST MAJORITY THAT INSURERS ARE
NOT GOING TO RECOUP THAT- IN
THE TUBBS FIRE ALONE IN MY NECK
OF THE WOODS ONLY TALK ABOUT
COST. WHOSE TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN INSURANCE PAYOUTS
TWELVE BILLION IN THE CAMPFIRE
IT WAS NINE BILLION. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL COSTS ON
THE FRONT END BUT LET'S JUST BE
HONEST. THE MORE WORK WE HAVE
IN THE FRONT IN THE CHEAPER
IT'S GOING TO BE LONGER TERM
FOR HOMEOWNERS IN CELLS. WE
CAN'T IGNORE THAT FACT ON THE
LAWSUIT THE TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
LAWSUITS ARE IN- TIE IN SAN
DIEGO AND THEN IN MY NECK OF
THE WOODS. AND LAKE COUNTY IS
BECAUSE PER THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THEY DID NOT COMPLETE
PROPER FIRE MITIGATION VIA
SEQUEL THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
SO WE HAVE THIS BILL THAT WOULD
CITY STATE THAT WOULD ESTABLISH
A STATEWIDE STANDARD RIGHT NOW
IT'S BEING DONE AN AD HOC BASIS
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD HUNDREDS
IF NOT THOUSANDS OF UNITS IN A
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES WHY
WOULDN'T WE WANT TO HAVE THESE
MEDICATIONS. I GOTTA BE HONEST
ABOUT IT AND EVEN WITHOUT THIS
BILL THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
GO AFTER. THOSE DEVELOPMENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT UPHOLDING
THEIR END ON SEQUEL WHEN IT
COMES TO WHILE FAR MITIGATION
THERE'S A REASON WHY. I
INDUSTRY SPENDING FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS RIGHT NOW ON A MEDIA
CAMPAIGN AGAINST THIS BILL.
IT'S UNHEARD OF. THIS BILL
PASSED THIS LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A
STRONGER VERSION OF THIS BILL
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT JUST BEING
HONEST ABOUT IT I'M NOT AN
ALTERNATE YOUR FRUSTRATION
MISTER ROGERS I COULD TELL YOU
LOVE THE VICE YEAR HE ALWAYS
MAKES HIMSELF INCREDIBLY
AVAILABLE BUT I JUST GOT TO SAY
WE HAVE. CONFORM THIS BILL TO
THE SAME BILL THAT EVERYONE
VOTED ON THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN OPR STANDARDS LAST YEAR.
THE MAIN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL WERE NEUTRAL LAST YEAR. ON
ONE EIGHTY TWO. SO I SAY ALL
THAT IS. WE DO BELIEVE THAT
WE'VE COME A LONG WAY IN
COMPROMISE YOU HAVE MY WORD SIR
IT WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
COMPROMISE. I AM NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IN ME TOO
BECAUSE THAT'S WHO I AM AND
THAT'S WHAT I REALLY BELIEVE IN
AND I REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN
GET EVENTUALLY IF WE'RE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO BE A TO GET THIS BILL
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. THANK
YOU MR GRUBER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- WHAT I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR YOU'RE ALWAYS SO
GENEROUS AND KIND AND YOU
COMPLEMENT THE PEOPLE TO COME
TO YOUR COMMITTEES AND I WANT
TO EXTEND THAT SAME COURTESY TO
YOU I THINK THERE'S NO ONE HERE
THAT DOUBTS HOW MUCH YOU CARE
ABOUT- ISSUES RELATED TO
WILDFIRES AND- REALLY HAVE BEEN
A CHAMPION ON THESE ISSUES AS
YOU LAID OUT FOR A PERIOD OF
YEARS NOW AND WAS. REMARKING
TO- IT'S AMAZING WAS MARKETS
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
DRIVING FROM THE AIRPORT TODAY
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WELL- FOREVER BLIND.
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE SURF
DURING THIS DECADE. IS THE FACT
THAT. ALMOST ALL OF US HAVE
HAVE WILDFIRES TEAR THROUGH A
COMMITTEE. OUR COMMUNITIES AND
CERTAINLY THAT WAS THE CASE FOR
ME- JUST A FEW MONTHS AFTER
BEING ELECTED WITH THE WHEN THE
WEALTHY FIRE. TORE THROUGH MANY
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
VICE CHAIRMAN TRENT- AND I WAS
A SEARING EXPERIENCE FOR ME-
AND FOR MY COMMUNITY AND I. I
SUSPECT THAT THE REASON YOU'VE
GOTTEN SUCH. STRICT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT TO PASS IS BECAUSE
EVERYONE IN THIS LEGISLATURE
APPRECIATES THAT WILDFIRE IS A-
AN EXTRAORDINARILY CHALLENGING.
AND TIMELY AND URGENT PUBLIC
POLICY CRISIS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE REASON I
SUSPECT YOU'RE GETTING A LITTLE
CONCERNED TODAY AND REASON I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS BILL ALL RIGHT
VERY MUCH COMMEND YOU FOR WHERE
YOU'RE GOING. IS BECAUSE- THIS
BILL IS AT THE INTERSECTION OF
TWO TWO OF OUR BIGGEST PUBLIC
POLICY CHALLENGES ON ONE HAND
WILDFIRES. AND ON THE OTHER
HAND ARE HOUSING AND HOMELESS
CRISIS AND IT'S WHICH HAVE ONLY
GROWN. MORE URGENT IN IN IN
RECENT YEARS. AND SO I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM FROM
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES AND I
WANT TO ADD MY VOICE TO THAT.
IS CONCERNED ABOUT STRIKING THE
RIGHT BALANCE AND THREADING
THAT NEEDLE AS OUR AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY PUT IT.
QUITE ELOQUENTLY- YOU KNOW I
HEARD WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THIS.
NIGHT PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM
BUILDING BUT THE QUESTION FOR
ME IS THIS GOING TO MAKE
HOUSING. MORE EXPENSIVE.
UNNECESSARILY I THINK THAT'S
THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE FIFTY
ON- YOU KNOW SO I WAS VERY
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT. THE PROGRESS. ON
SEE WHAT YOU'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE
AND I WANT TO LEND MY VOICE. TO
THOSE EXPRESSING. CONCERN ON
THAT ISSUE. THE OTHER THING I
DID WANT TO BRING UP WITH YOU
AND I KNOW WE HAVEN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT IT IS
THAT. THE LETTER OF OPPOSITION
FROM KIND OF LOS ANGELES- I
KNOW THAT THAT WAS WAS LATE
OPPOSITION AND THINK I CAN'T
DEFEND THEM ON THE PROCESS
THERE- BUT BUT I DON'T THINK
THE FACT THAT THEIR- THEIR
ARGUMENTS WERE REYES LATE MEANS
THAT WE SHOULD. WE THREATEN OUR
THEM CORRECT AND YOU KNOW WHAT
THE WHAT THE COUNTY SAYS THAT
WHILE THIS BILL IS GENERALLY IN
LINE WITH THE DIRECTION THAT
LOS ANGELES IS COUNTY ITSELF IS
MOVING. IT GOES WELL ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT IS REQUIRED
CREATING UNNECESSARY AND COSTLY
HURDLES AND REALLY. PLAN PACKED
WITH FUTURE PROJECTS AND THINGS
IN DEVELOPMENT ITSELF. I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHAT SORT OF WHAT YOUR
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ABOUT
THAT THAT'S ONE OF MY- ONE OF
MY CONCERNS. WHAT WHAT
COMMITMENTS YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO MAKE IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
THAT ISSUE- AND THEN THE OTHER
IS. IS ON- YOU KNOW BECAUSE ONE
OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAS BEEN
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION ABOUT-
YOU KNOW. WHETHER THE
REGULATIONS AND STANDARDS THAT
ARE ADOPTED ARE REASONABLE
FEASIBLE AND ACHIEVABLE AND
THAT. THIS NOTION OF. THAT
THAT- YOU KNOW THAT THAT A
MAJORITY OF THEM SHOULD BE AND
I YOU KNOW I THINK. CANDIDLY WE
SHOULD. AIM FOR HIGHER THAN
THAT AND I'M NOT SO WHAT OF.
GENERAL'S ABOUT. BUT IF WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THE- OF THAT. THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REGULATE THAT.
WE MAKE THE GOALS IN THE
STANDARDS YOU KNOW FEASIBLE AND
REASONABLE ACHIEVABLE TO MUCH
MUCH HIGHER LIKE A TIME I THINK
A 100% IS PROBABLY- ILLUSORY
AND IN ANY CASE BY. BUT
CERTAINLY. TO ME THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOMETHING BETWEEN FORTY NINE
AND A HUNDRED SO. THAT'S
ANOTHER CONCERN I HAVE AGAIN I
AM. YOU KNOW. EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOALS OF THIS
BILL. I THINK THAT THERE IS AN
URGENT CRISIS- I COMMEND YOU
FOR THE EXTRAORDINARY WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE IN THIS AREA. OVER
A PERIOD OF TIME. BUT I DON'T
WANT TO GET IN EARLY EXACERBATE
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
EXACERBATE OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
FURTHER DRIVE UP THE COST OF
HOUSING YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW
YOU AND YOUR WIFE STRUGGLE TO
STAY. IN THE HOUSE THAT YOU
WERE RAISED IN. I HEAR ALL THE
TIME FOR PEOPLE WHO GREW UP IN
MY COMMUNITY THAT. THEY THEY
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
THE COMMUNITY I GREW UP AND
IT'S A HOW DO WE STRIKE THAT
APPROPRIATEBALANCE- WOULD LOVE
TO HEAR. YOUR THOUGHTS ON SOME
OF THESE PLEASE POINTS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MISTER SENATE APPRECIATE
THAT. FIRST AND FOREMOST ON. A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY YEAH NO
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT REGARD
TO WIN EVER- IN INDIVIDUAL.
BRINGS FOR OPPOSITION IT'S
MERITED WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION- SO I'LL
JUST SAY THIS- WE'VE HAD. SOME
INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH- L.
A. COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES. I
BELIEVE THAT TWO DAYS- AND THEN
CENTER IN FRONT OF YOU TO TAKE
A- STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I KNOW THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE. MORE
CONVERSATIONS AND I DO BELIEVE.
THAT IF YOU WERE TO TALK AT
WHICH I KNOW YOU HAVE. BUT IF
ANYWHERE TO TALK WITH L. A.
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES. THEY
WOULD SAY THAT WERE MORE THAN
WILLING AND WANTING TO ENGAGE.
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE
ABLE TO- FIGURE THIS OUT WITH
HIM. ON THE ISSUE OF
ACHIEVABLE. I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THAT THIS DOESN'T THE NEW RAGS
ON THIS. BASE OFF. OF FEEDBACK-
THAT WE HEARD AT THE END OF
LAST YEAR. WE WON'T EVEN SEE
THIS GOING. TO AFFECT UNTIL THE
NEXT RENEWAL CYCLE. SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT NINE AND A HALF
TíNH YOU. DOWN THE- RIGHT-
INTO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO BE ABLE TO FOCUS
ON HERE TODAY. THE OTHER IECES
THAT- MISS CLARK SILVA I ASKED
MISS WEEKES ALSO ASK. IS ON THE
ISSUE ND I THINK IT'S- WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS AND I DON'T WANNA BES
WHATSOEVER. WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT ON THE ISSUE OF SEQUEL-
AND- WHERE THAT SWEET SPOT IS.
I TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT IF
WE CAN LAND THIS. WITH INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES. ON WHERE'D-
THE APPROVAL PROCESS IS. AND
HOW HOUSING- SORT SO THE
EXAMPLE I GAVE IS. IF YOU
ALREADY HAVE YOUR TENTATIVE MAP
FOR EXAMPLE. A TENTATIVE MAP
CAN BE- CAN STAY. IN PLACE FOR.
OVER TEN YEARS. WE'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN GOING THERE. IF
YOU HAVE. A DEVELOPMENT THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN PROCESS OR-
WHETHER IT'S A PLANNING LEVEL
OR- IN FRONT OF A LOCAL
GOVERNING BODY. I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT THAT SHOULD BE A
FOCUS IN ON THAT ECAUSE IT
DOES NOT HAVE APPROVAL- THERE
IS AN EXAMPLE I'M NOT USING
THIS THAT KICKED THE DOG
WHATSOEVER BUT- IF WOULD OCCUR
CUT FOR EXAMPLE- KICK IN.
ADDITIONAL RAGS OR A
RECIRCULATION OF THE DEVICE
THAT I DOCUMENT THAT IS NOT OUR
INTENTION WHATSOEVER AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO CLARIFY THAT- THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY IS I THINK. JUST
BEING HONEST ABOUT IT AND I
ALWAYS WANNA BE TRANSPARENT I
THINK THAT THE PIECE WHERE WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT. HOW DO WE
HAVE A BILL. THAT'S GOING TO
PROTECT RESIDENTS. AND MEET
WHERE- INDUSTRY NEEDS ARE JUST
BEING CANDID AND WILL CONTINUE
TO ME ON THAT AND I WANT TO
FIND A COMPROMISE SO THAT WE
CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER AND BEGIN
HOPEFULLY GET A BIPARTISAN.
VOTE ON THE FLOOR. YEAH I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT THAT VERY
MUCH AND- YOU'RE JUST A PLATE
IF I RESPOND TO IT YOU KNOW. I
KNOW HOW HARD YOU WORK YOUR
BILLS- AND I THINK THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE SO IMPORTANT
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THE STEPS
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS. YOU KNOW
IF I COULD SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF I THINK WHAT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO SEE PERHAPS SOME OF THE
OTHER FOLKS ON THIS COMMITTEE
IS IN A DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS
MAYBE MAYBE A FEW MORE STEPS
RIGHT YOU'VE YOU'VE MENTIONED
THE SWEET SPOT AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S EXACTLY THE RIGHT WAY- I
WANT YOU TO BE SUCCESSFUL I
THINK THIS IS AN- EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BELT. I THINK A LOT
OF MY COLLEAGUES FEEL THE SAME
WAY BUT I'LL TELL YOU IT DOES
GIVE ME SOME PAUSE WHEN I HEAR
SOMEONE WHO SERVED AS A
FIREFIGHTER FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AND RETIRED AS A
BATTALION CHIEF TELL ME. AND
ALSO SERVE IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TELL ME THAT THEY THINK THIS
BILL DOESN'T HIT THE MARK- YOU
KNOW THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THAT THAT MAKES AN IMPACT.
SO WHICH- GOING TO DO-
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS AS
YOU ALWAYS DO TO WORK THESE
THINGS HARD TO LISTEN TO
EVERYBODY- YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
GO BACK AND HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITHTHE COUNTY THAT I'M
PRIVILEGED TO REPRESENT- AND TO
TRY TO HIT THAT SWEET SPOT. I
THINK WE WOULD ALL LOVE TO GET
BEHIND YOU AND SEE THIS BILL
SIGNED INTO LAW- AND JUST HOPE
THAT WE CAN AGAIN. THIS THIS
VERY. IMPORTANT BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
THAN PROTECTING MY COMMITTEE
FROM WIDE FIRE. BUT I ALSO HEAR
EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR FOLKS IN
MY COMMUNITY A HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS AND SODA IN
ADVERSELY. EXACERBATE THAT
PROBLEM. IS SOME I WANT TO
AVOID IT IF YOU CAN FIND THAT
SWEET SPOT I THINK WE'D ALL BE
DELIGHTED. INDIA INDIA MY
COMMITMENT AND- YOU KNOW AGAIN
I THINK PART OF A COALITION
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. SUPPORT THE BILL.
NO THAT THERE NEED TO BE
DIGITAL STANDARDS IN THIS- AND-
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT WE'RE
GOING TO. CONTINUE TO WORK.
TALK- IN. AGAIN I KNOW THE
ULTIMATE BACKSTOP IS THIS. IF
WE CAN'T GET THIS FIGURED OUT-
IT IS NOT GOING TO PASS THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR JUST BEING VERY
HONEST ABOUT IT- IN SO IT IS. A
MISSION THAT I NEED TO BEYOND
TO TRY TO BE A TO FIGURE OUT.
WHERE THAT COMPROMISE IS. AGAIN
I THINK WHERE I WANT TO FIND A
COMPROMISE. IS NOT. JUST BEING
BLUNT. WE CAN'T NEUTER THIS
BILL. BECAUSE THE STAKES ARE
TOO HIGH. AND WANT TO BE ABLE
TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY. TO TRY
TO BE ABLE TO. MEET THEM.
HALFWAY AND I WOULD HOPE THAT
THERE WOULD BE- RECIPROCAL.
AGREEMENT THAT. WE CAN. LAND
THE BILL IN A SWEET SPOT. YEAH
I THINK THAT'S I THINK YOU'VE
YOU'VE YOU'VE SAID THE RIGHT
THINGS AND I APPRECIATE THAT I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY UP HERE.
YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
YOU TO NEUTER THE SPELL AND
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
KEEP WORKING WITH INDUSTRY AND
AGAIN ALSO WITH THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES TO. TO FIND THAT
SWEET SPOT 100% THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU CENTER. TRULY
HEY FINAL COMMENTS. I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THANK
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND THANK OF
OUR COLLEAGUES FOR A TRULY
ROBUST CONVERSATION IN RECENT
DAYS I THINK IT HAS BEEN SAID
SEVERAL TIMES READY THESE ARE
VERY HARD ISSUES ON THE ONE
HAND WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE THE
INCREDIBLE IMMEDIATE CRISIS OF
WILDFIRES ON THE OTHER HAND WE
HAVE THE LONGER TERM ONGOING
CRISIS WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING- I WILL SAY FOR ONE I
THINK THE AYE AYE AYE A VERY
MUCH- BELIEVE- THE AUTHOR IS
DOING HIS. DARN HARDEST TO
STRIKE A BALANCE HERE- AND
CERTAINLY- AS WAS ALLUDED TO-
THIS IS NOT THE BILL THAT WE
WERE THAT MANY OF US VOTED ON
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS- THIS IS
A MORE MODEST BILL COMPARED SB
ONE EIGHTY TWO THIS IS THE
THIRD YEAR THE DISCUSSION OF I
WANTED TO OUR COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE I'VE CERTAINLY HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF YOU IN RECENT
DAYS- APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
FOCUS ON THIS- CERTAINLY THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAD FRANKLY OVER
THE WEEKEND TO- BRING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE ARE. GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE ROUTE
HOW WE MINIMIZE THE IMPACT ON
SEQUEL OF SEQUEL ON MINISTERIAL
PERMITS- HOW WE ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT IMPACTING-
IMPROVEMENTS BEYOND THE
PROPERTY LINE HOW WE ARE
LIMITING THIS TO RESIDENTIAL
NOT COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL THIS
CAME ABOUT BECAUSE THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAD IN THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT I WOULD SAY THE
AUTHOR I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
LOUDLY AND CLEARLY THAT THERE
IS STILL- IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD- I SUSPECT FOR A NUMBER
OF OUR COLLEAGUES. THESE ARE
CERTAINLY COURTESY VOTES WITH
THE HOPE THAT THESE ILL GET
RESOLVED I WILL SAY ON THE TWO
MAJOR ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED I VIEW THEM BOTH- AS
REQUIRING FINE TUNE COMPROMISES
AND LET ME JUST SAY MORE
EXPLICITLY WHEN IT COMES TO
GRANDFATHERING I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND. THAT IF THERE WERE
EXPECTATIONS BY DEVELOPERS- IT
IS ABSOLUTELY FAIR TO SAY THAT
THOSE EXPECTATIONS OUGHT TO BE
RESPECTED BUT ON THE OTHER HAND
AS WE STATED IN THE ANALYSIS-
CLIMB THE CHANGES ARE. REAL AND-
THESE. MAY HAVE BEEN SET AT A
TIME BEFORE WE SAW. THE HAVOC
OF WILDFIRES IN RECENT DAYS AND
LAID OUT IN THE ANALYSIS I DO
THINK WE NEED A VERY FINE TUNED
BALANCE AND I'VE BEEN PUSHING
BOTH SIDES TO CONSIDER THAT. ON
THE LANGUAGE OF FEASIBLE
ACHIEVABLE FOR MAJORITY
DEVELOPMENTS- I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE. THE PERSPECTIVE
THAT THAT MIGHT NOT BE THE
RIGHT BUT THE EXACT RIGHT POINT
WE WANT TO END UP. BUT I WAS
ALSO I WOULD ALSO SUGGESTED I
DON'T THINK THE ANSWER IS ALL
OR NOTHING HERE. WE'VE GOT A
STRIKE A BALANCE AND SO A PART
OF MY COMMENTS TODAY IS TO
REALLY ENCOURAGE. IF THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD- CONTINUE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE TO THE
SENATORS POINT. I DO THINK IF
WE DON'T RESOLVE THESE ISSUES-
IT WILL LIKELY NOT BODE WELL.
ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND I
KNOW THAT OUR COLLEAGUES ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING WITH THIS ONE
SO- WITH THAT- I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS TODAY- AGAIN I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THIS
AUTHOR BECAUSE HE WORKS. AS
HARD AS ANYONE IN THIS BUSINESS
TO FIND THOSE BALANCES- I THINK
THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS WILL BE
IF THIS BILL MOVES FOR WILL BE
CRITICAL- AND I'M HAPPY TO
ENGAGE IN. PART OF WHAT I WANT
TO SIGNAL IS MY OPENNESS TO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS HERE TO
GO TO LANDED AT THE RIGHT PLACE
CERTAINLY DO NOT THINK THAT. WE
HAVE PROBABLY A FINAL PRODUCT
COMING OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK ON THE OTHER HAND
THE URGENCY OF THE MATTER OF
THIS IDEA THT SOMEHOW WE HOLD
THIS FOR FOURTH YEAR THAT ALSO
DOESN'T SIT EXACTLY WELL- BUT
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT THE RIGHT ANSWER SO- WITH
THAT- AND LEICESTER ANY FINAL
COMMENTS I WANT TO TURN IT BACK
TO THE GOOD SENATOR FOR YOUR
FINAL COMMENTS. SHARES USUAL-
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT. TRULY WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO YOUR
AMAZING STAFF TEAM MEMBERS
THANK YOU KNOW HOW BUSY YOU ARE
THANK YOU FOR THIS ROBUST
CONVERSATION. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU- IF YOU
WOULD- RESPECTFULLY PROVIDE AN
AYE VTE TODAY I KNOW THAT WE
GOT WORK TO DO HERE IN THE
COMING WEEKS THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND MISTER CHAIR. AND WITH THAT
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND. A
SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOST IN TO
PASSAGE AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMEDIAN. CHU HI CHIU I SAY ARE
DON'T KNOW. THEY ARE THERE NO.
APRIL GABRIEL I. KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN CORK
SILVA NOT VOTING. THANKS
MONNING WICKS HI WICKS I. WAY
FOR THE MEMBERS TO COME BACK
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MEMBERS.
AND THAT BILLS ON CALL. LET'S
NOW GO TO SENATOR STERN FILE IN
TWO S. B. SIXTY THREE WELL IN
THE FIRST. IF YOU'RE- A MR
MAJORITY LEADER. ONE OF. FOR I
RECOGNIZE THE MOTION. RICHARD I
WANT TO TALK PASS YES- I THINK
THAT'S STILL A MOTION THAT I'M
PRESENTING SB SIXTY THREE. ALSO
ON THE TOPIC OF WILDFIRES.
DIFFERENT CHORUS OF SUPPORT
HERE WE'RE BUILDING INDUSTRIES
ACTUALLY ON THE SAME PAGE WITH-
OUR FIRE COMMUNITIES AND
CONSERVATION GROUPS AND- FIRE
CHIEFS AND UTILITIES- WISH WE
COULD FIND THE SAME- ON OTHER
FRONTS BUT I THINK THIS THESE
ISSUES THEY ALL AGREE ON WHICH
IS. THAT THE BUILDING STANDARDS
THAT VICE CHAIR BROUGHT UP VERY
ELOQUENTLY AND- IT IN YOU KNOW
UNDERSTANDS THE DETAILS OF WHAT
IT IS IT A LOCAL ZONING LEVEL
EXTENDING THOSE PROTECTIONS
BEYOND VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES TO MODERATE AND HIGH
ZONES IT'S GOING TO BE CRUCIAL.
MARSHALING A FIRE RESILIENCY
CORE LOCALLY SO PEOPLE CAN
ACTUALLY GO OUT AND DO THEIR
HARDENING OF THEIR HOMES
TOGETHER WILL BE CRUCIAL.
REFORMING OUR FIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS AND OTHER PROGRAMS
MOVING MONEY RIGHT NOW IN THE
COMMUNITIES WILL BE CRITICAL
LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE ROAD
SIDE TREATMENTS WHEN YOU DRIVE
DOWN THE ROAD AND YOU SEE.
MUSTARD GRASS GROWING TEN FOOT
HIGH ALONG THE ROAD SIDE AND
SOMEONE FLICKED A CIGARETTE.
IT'S NOT JUST POWER LINES FOLKS
IT'S THOSE HUMAN CAUSED FIRES
AS WELL SO I WE THINK THIS BILL
WILL BE APPROVED CRUCIAL. STEP
IN THAT PROCESS AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL I THINK
I'VE GOT TO. BOB RAYMER WITH
THE BUILDING INDUSTRY AND- WHO
IS MY OTHER SUPPORT HERE- AND I
THINK IT'S KATE DARKEN OUR
FORMER STATE FIRE MARSHAL- WHO
IS NOW WITH FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
CALIFORNIA. LET'S GO TO YOUR
WITNESSES PLACE THANK. YES
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
BOB RAYMER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY
THREE I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
INDICATE SUPPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION THE
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL OF
SHOPPING CENTERS. SB SIXTY
THREE WILL IMPROVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA AND
EXPAND THE APPLICATION OF THE
STATE FARM MARSHALL'S FIRE
HARDENING BUILDING STANDARDS
THE FIRE MARSHALS BUILDING
STANDARDS HAVE A PROVEN HISTORY
OF SUCCESS WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT TODAY IN THE PARADISE
FIRE HOMES THAT MATH OF THE
FIRE MARSHAL'S WILL BE BUILDING
STANDARDS AND HAD DEFENSIBLE
SPACE HAD A SURVIVAL RATE OF
THREE TO FOUR TIMES GREATER.
THAN THOSE THAT DID NOT
REGARDING OF THE STATE FARM
MAPS CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
FIRE MAPS WITH A VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES SB SIXTY THREE
REQUIRES THE DIRECTOR OF CAL
FIRE TO COMPLETE THE SAME MAPS-
FOR MODERATE AND HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES ONCE THESE MAPS
ARE COMPLETED AND CERTIFIED BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS STATE FARM
MARSHALL DEPARTMENT A HOUSING
WILL ADOPT BUILDING STANDARDS
EXPANDING THE APPLICATION OF
OUR EXISTING WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE STANDARDS TO THE
HIGH. FIRE SEVERITY ZONES AND
THESE AGENCIES. MANAGE SHOULD
BE FURTHER EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
THE MODERATE FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES SENATORS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AND FIRE HARDENING WORKS
AND WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU HELLO EVERYONE
THIS IS KATE JARGON RETIRED
STATE FIRE MARSHAL FOR
CALIFORNIA AND CURRENTLY
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEF COUNSEL
OF WHICH I'M A CO CHAIR WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SIXTY
THREE. SENATOR STERN HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE LEADERS. IN THE
LEGISLATURE THESE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND THE EFFORTS OF
WILDFIRE PREVENTION MITIGATION
IN BOTH HIS ROLE AS CHAIR FOR
THE SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AND ADVOCACY IS A
MEMBER. THE FIRE STATE COUNCIL
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE
BECAUSE IN ADVANCE IS THE GOAL
OF CREATING A MORE STRUCTURED
AND ROBUST DEFENSIBLE SPACE
PROGRAM. FOR STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION. WE HAVE ALWAYS
HAD A SUPPLY AND DEMAND GAP
PROBLEM WITH DEFENSIBLE SPACE
TOO MANY HOUSES TOO FEW
INSPECTORS. WE NEED HOMEOWNER
AND RESIDENT ACTIONS AT THE
LEVEL OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CONVERSATIONS VISITS AND
INSPECTIONS PER YEAR AND THIS
BILL CREATES A FRAMEWORK FOR
CALIFORNIA. GOVERNMENT
VOLUNTEERS IN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO COME TOGETHER AND
BUILD THAT CAPACITY. THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE STATE COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIXTY
THREE BECAUSE IT DANCES ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR A HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND MITIGATION. AND THAT
HOLISTIC APPROACH INCLUDES%
CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND LAND USE
PLANNING IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
COMMUNITY HARDENING STANDARDS.
HOME HARDENING STANDARDS AND
PROGRAMS DEFENSIBLE SPACE
STANDARDS PROGRAMS INSURANCE
SUSTAINABILITY. A WILDFIRE
COMMUNITY CERTIFICATION PROCESS
AND A SINGULAR TWENTY YEAR PLAN
THAT DETAILS FUNDING FUNDING
OPERATIONS AND METRICS FOR
BUILDING COMMUNITY WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY FOR CALIFORNIA. AND
A PLAN THAT UNIFIES THE MANY
MANY VERY WILD FIRE PLANS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST OUT THERE FOR
EXAMPLE. ARE FORCED. MANAGEMENT
TASK FORCE ACTION PLAN. THE
BORDER FORCE STRATEGIC PLAN HOW
FIRE AND THE FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES FIRE PLANS. THE
REGIONAL FORCE DIDN'T FIRE
CONSERVE IT. SHOULD MAKE A PATH
TO BUILDING PROGRAM PLANNING.
AB THIRTY EIGHT DRIVEN HELLO
YES HOME HARDENING PROGRAM.
HELP FIRES WILDFIRE PREVENTION
GRANTS PROGRAM UNDER THE
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS. ARE
UTILITY WILDFIRE PLANS
COMMUNITY WILDFIRE PROTECTION
PLANS AND LOCAL AND GOVERNMENT
GENERAL PLANS LOCAL EMERGENCY
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS AND I
COULD CONTINUE THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF PLANS OUT THERE. WE
ADVOCATE FOR BRINGING THEM
TOGETHER WE THINK SENATE BILL
SIXTY THREE GOES A LONG WAY
TOWARD BUILDING- CAPACITY
ESPECIALLY FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORTED.
YEAH THAT'S IT. IN ORDER TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH
TO STATE THEIR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- AT THIS TIME MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CAN SIMPLY STATE
THEIR NAME THE ORGANIZATION AND
THE FACT OF THEIR SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM GOING TO THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS. NOT
GOING TO THE PHONE LINES MADAM
OPERATOR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB SIXTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHAT A LINE
NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO REMEMBER REMEMBER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE ONE PAIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. I NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS ERIN EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
TREE CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CATHERINE BORG FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
WHEN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AS A BRED BERYL WITH TO
BUILD STRONG COALITION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY THREE THANK
YOU. FIND ONE HUNDRED AND TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
ABDALLAH MILES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS- SUPPORTING.
ONE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON ACTUALLY JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIXTY THREE. BUT FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE THERE'S
NO MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESS TO
THIS SO LET US SEE IF THEY'RE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL THERE'S NO ONE HERE
IN THIS COMMITTEE ROOM. NOR AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LET'S GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THEY WISH TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR SB
SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
POSITION IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY DISCUSSION. TO THE
MOISTURE I THANK YOU FOR BRING
YOUR BILL FORWARD I THINK THIS
BILL HAS A LOT MORE OF AN
ELEMENT OF ALLOWING LOCAL
AGENIES. I NOT ONLY TO OBTAIN
INFORMATION THAT CAN BE HELPFUL
TO THEM BUT IT DOES NOT
RESTRICT THEM FROM. YOUR LOCAL
DECISION MAKING AND THAT THAT
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR A
LOT OF LOCAL AGENCIES SO- IN MY
READING THAT WRONG THIS NO
THAT'S THAT HAPPENED TO BE A
LOCAL AGENCIES WILL STILL BE
ABLE TO DO WHAT THEY WANT. AND
THEY NEED TO DO AND DO THE
LOCAL DECISION MAKING SO ANYWAY
AND THEN PLUS WE HAVEN'T FUNDED
THIS YEAR CORRECT I PRUNING.
OKAY I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
ELSE THAT NEEDS TO BE WORKED ON
FOR ALL OF US IS TO ENSURE
THAT- BECAUSE THAT'S THEIR BIG
ROADBLOCK IS GETTING THE
RESOURCES AND IDENTIFYING
PROJECTS ONCE THEY'RE
IDENTIFIED BEING ABLE TO PUT
HIM OUT. AND GET THEM DONE. WE
NEED FUNDING TO DO THAT AND I
THINK THAT THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY HAVE
TO WORK ON YOURSELF. RESHAPE
YOUR BILL AND I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY THANK YOU
THANKS. ANY OTHER COMMENTS JUST
WHAT THOSE EMOTIONS ARE SECOND.
I DON'T WANT TO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD
AND NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY EXPANDING. MEASURES
THAT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN
THE PAST- TWO OTHER ERRORS THE
STATE THAT CONTINUE TO FACE THE
RISK OF FIRE DAMAGE- APPRECIATE
YOUR- THOUGHTFULNESS IMMINENT
AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT TODAY ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- NICK KNOWLEDGE MINT-
IT. THIS IS THE INCENTIVES
BASED APPROACH TO SOME EXTENT
BUT I THINK THE STANDARD
SETTING HERE WILL CONTINUE TO
PUSH THE ENVELOPE I THINK WE
CAN KEEP STRIVING. TO HARDEN
WE'RE NOT THERE YET I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD ADMIT THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE AS THEY
POSSIBLY CAN BE EVEN WHEN-
THERE THE NEW BEST IN CLASS
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING
DAILY. AND THAT FIRE RISK
ITSELF AS WELL SO- HOPEFULLY
SILVA CHART A PATH FORWARD AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MADAM SIR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO. HI CHIU ICE
THEY ARE TOO HIGH THE R. DI
EVERY YEAR. KALRA KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN CORK SILVA. THANKS
TO BYE WEEKS. THANK YOU YOUR
BILL CYCLE. CENTER HERTZBERG
FILE ITEM THREE SB THREE FOUR
FOUR. I'M OF THE BILL HM
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND I'LL MAKE IT SHORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS WE- GRAPPLE WITH
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO DEAL WITH
THE INTRACTABLE PROBLEMS. WELL
FACING HOPE HOMELESSNESS THIS
IS A CREATIVE SOLUTION THAT
WORKED A FEW YEARS AGO- WE DID
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET WE JUST GOT TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET NOW THIS
SETS UP THE PROGRAM NECESSARY
FOR. FOLKS WHO HAVE PETS WE
SPEND SO MUCH MONEY TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZEPEOPLE TO. LEAVE
THE STREETS TO GOING TO SHELTER
IN ONE OF THE REASONS WE'VE
LEARNED NUMBERS ARE DIFFERENT
WERE FROM 5225% OF PEOPLE HAVE
PETS THEY WON'T DO IT BECAUSE
THEY WON'T LEAVE. THEIR PET ON
THE STREET SO WE PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES FOR THE PETS FITNESS
SERVICE AND OTHERS. AND I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY FROM
MY OWN SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THE
GREAT INCREDIBLE CAN CRAFT
PRESIDENT OF HOPE OF THE VALLEY
RESCUE MISSION THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. WHO IS A HERTZBERG HERO
AND HAS DONE THE UNBELIEVABLE
NUMBER OF GREAT THINGS IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE RECIPIENTS OF
THE GRANTS WE HAD A FEW YEARS
AGO. I CAN TELL YOU THE STORY
OF HOW SUCCESSFUL IT WAS I
PROMISED WHEN WE DID THE FIVE
MILLION I WAS GOING TO DOUBLE
IT WE GOT THE TEN MILLION ON
THE BUDGET. AND NOW WE WANT TO
SET THE PROGRAM UP AND MAKE
THIS PERMANENT BECAUSE FOR SO
LITTLE DOLLARS AND SUCH A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT PROCESS IT
HELPS DEAL WITH HOMELESSNESS
AND- AS WE SAY BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SIR. HERE FROM YOUR
HERTZBERG HERE I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT'S A TRADEMARK OF ALL-
EXPRESSION BUT- IT'S IT IS
ALRIGHT WE HAVE OUR OWN. ALL
VOTE FOR. MISTER KRAFT. WELL
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE ABLE TO SHARE JUST A COUPLE
MINUTES WITH YOU BUT YOU KNOW
EVERY DAY MYSELF AND OUR TEAM
WERE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO TRY
TO HELP PEOPLE ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES THAT HAVE LED TO THEIR
HOMELESSNESS AND OFTENTIMES
IT'S REALLY CONVINCING THEM AND
PERSUADING THEM AND ASSISTING
THEM AND PROVIDING THEM THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET AND YOU KNOW
THE B. MAYBE YOU'VE HEARD
RECENTLY ABOUT THE TINY HOMES
OR THE CABIN COMMUNITIES WHICH
HAS BEEN A- VITAL PART OF
GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
WIND BECAUSE IT PROVIDES. SOME
PRIVACY INCOME INDEPENDENCE AND
THERE'S A LOCK THE FRONT DOOR
BUT AS A SENATOR KNOWS SO WELL
ONE OF THE MAIN BARRIERS THAT
OFTEN TIMES PREVENTS PEOPLE
FROM COMING INSIDE IS THEIR
PETS THEY LOVE THEIR PETS LIKE
YOUR CHILDREN AND I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW MANY TIMES I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO TALK TO PEOPLE AND THE
FIRST QUESTION AND THEY TABLE
WALL WOULD YOU TAKE PADS AND WE
THINK YES AND- THEY THEIR FACE
JUST LIKE THAT BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE THAT NOW THERE IS A
PATHWAY BACK TOWARDS. SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND WHOLENESS AND-
IN IN BEING ABLE TO ACCESS THE
RESOURCES THAT WE CAN GIVE
THEM- AND I AND I GOT A I GOT A
LOT OF TIME IS GOING TO THE
VERY END AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR WILL LOCK YOU HAVE SIXTEEN
DIFFERENT SHELTERS AND WE WILL
HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
THIRTY TOO BAD SINCE I SPENT A
LOT OF TIMES GOING TO DIFFERENT
SHELTERS AND THE ANIMALS
ACTUALLY BRING SO MUCH OF LIFE
AND ENCOURAGEMENT TO NOT JUST
THE OWNERS OF THOSE PADS BUT
THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE AND SO-
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE SITE
THAT WE MIGHT. THAT WE OPERATE
ON ON CHANDLER BOULEVARD IT IT
HAD YOU KNOW SIXTY FIVE PEOPLE
IN IT BUT IT HAD EIGHT DOGS
AND- IT IS REALLY A PLACE OF
JOY WHEN THE DOCTOR OUT THERE
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE DOG
INVOLVED LIKE THEY THEY BELONG
TO EVERYBODY AND SO I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND THE BENEFITS OF
VETERINARY CARE OF GETTING A
SHOT AT GETTING AND YOU KNOW.
THE FLEAS AND TICKS THAT THE
CALL ALRP ALL THE THING THAT
ARE FROM. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR. CENTER
HERTZBERG FOR. REBEL THE BILL.
AND I HOPE WILL PASS. CONTINUE
TO- PEOPLE- AND ALSO THEIR
FURRY FRIENDS. LET'S SEE IF
THEY'RE THE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYONE OF THE
REMOTE. TESTIMONY STATIONS. TO
THE OPERATOR ONE ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. IT'S THREE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS Y. NETS
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN IN
CUBA WERE TO LIGHT NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
PREPARING CLEATS TO SUPPORT SB
THREE FORTY FOUR AND A HALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA AND
SANTIAGO HUMANE SOCIETY THANK
YOU SENATOR HATCH BURKE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CORPORAN WITH
THE PLAN NUMBER KAREN LYING
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION THE STATE
WITH THE CREATION OF ANIMAL
SHELTERS AND SUPPORT ALONG WITH
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRIS ROSE- ON BEHALF OF THE
PET INSURERS NAAFI AT THE NORTH
AMERICAN PET HEALTH INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHARING
INVOLVEMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PERSONAL TO TALK
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DEREK DAHLKE ON
BEHALF THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR CURRENT NUMBER ALL
OF THE ARTICLES ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AT THE PORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CARE VICE CHAIRMAN STEPHEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ELIZABETH
WORK ON BEHALF OF BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY IN OUR THOUSAND
THE CALIFORNIA SUPPORTERS
MEMBERS PARTNERS AND STAFF IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY FOUR TO SUPPORT HOMELESS
SHELTERS AND BREAK HEALTHY
HOUSING INSURANCE OF OUR STATE.
MOLDABLE INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
PETS WE THANK YOU AND WE THANK
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND NUMBER CAITLYN
JOHNSON WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF MARS AND
ROPER AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU LET'S NOW GO TO ANY
OPPOSITION THERE IS NO. MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESS AND- I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM NOR IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS TO
THE OPERATOR LET'S OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANYONE THAT MAY WANT
TO STATE THEIR OPPOSITION. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. BRING BACK TO KENNY ANY
COMMENTS DISCUSSIONS. THIS
QUICK SILVA- WHAT DID YOU SAY
BOTH ENDS OF THE LEASH BOTH
ENDS OF THE LEASE. ENDS OF THE
LEASH WELL I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL- YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
WHEN WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS- YOU
KNOW PEOPLE WANT TO HELP
THEY'RE JUST NOT REALLY SURE
WHAT TO DO BUT THEN THERE'S
ALSO THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
WHICH IS A LOT OF JUDGMENT. AND
THE JUDGMENT OR THINGS THAT I
HAVE HEARD OFF ON ALMOST A
DAILY BASIS THINGS LIKE THOSE
PEOPLE WITH THOSE THINGS OR WHY
WOULD WE WANT TO ACCOMMODATE
THEIR ANIMALS THINGS LIKE THAT
AND- YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN
NOVELS WRITTEN FOR THE
BEGINNING OF TIME OF MAN'S BEST
FRIEND. AND MANY TIMES MAN
BESSEREN HAVE BEEN ANIMALS-
SOME OF OUR MOST BRILLIANT
CLASSIC NOVELS ARE ABOUT DOGS
AND THEIR OWNERS. AND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ARE
NO DIFFERENT THEY BECOME VERY
ATTACHED. TO SOMETIMES IT
REALLY IS THE ONLY CONTACT THEY
HAVE I MEAN IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT
ANYBODY GOES UP TO SOMEBODY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
GIVE THEM A HUG AND SOMETIMES
ARE ONLY PHYSICAL. CONTACT WE
HAVE THERAPY DOGS IN OUR
AIRPORTS WE HAVE THEM IN
HOSPITALS AND WE KNOW THAT
PETS- PARTICULARLY DOGS- VERY
MUCH THERAPY. FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE REALLY STRUGGLING SO I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL I HOPE
THAT- WITH THESE FUNDS THAT CAN
BE EXPANDED. BECAUSE A SHELTER
CERTAINLY IS A PLACE OUT. OF
FIRM PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO GO INDOORS BUT
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT A HOME AND
HAVING. AND ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
WHO ARE- ON THE STREETS COME
INDOORS IS GOING TO BE ONE OF
THE ONLY WAYS FOR US TO START
TO GET THE RECOVERY WE- THAT WE
REALLY ALL DESPERATELY WANT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL. YEAH
I WOULD- MOVE THE BELL THANK
THANK THE MAJORITY LEADER FOR
HIS ACCENT EXCELLENT
REPRESENTATION OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. THANK YOU AND
A LOT OF TIME TO CRAFT FOR ALL
THE EXTRAORDINARY WORK HE DOES
AND I JUST WANT TO COMPLIMENT
YOU SENATOR FOR A REALLY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH HERE IT HAS
THE SENSITIVITY AND- CREATIVITY
THAT I THINK ARE PART OF YOUR
TRADE MARKS SO THANK YOU IN
PLACE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU. THE BILLS ARE
MOVED AND SECONDED AND I JUST
WANT TO ALSO THANK THE AUTHOR
THIS IS- BASED ON A CONCEPT
THAT I'VE SUPPORTED FOR YEARS
AND APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP
IN THIS AREA AS WELL AS YOUR-
DOG PURSUE TO FUNDING WHICH- IS
ACTUALLY FAIRLY RARE BEFORE WE
MOVE FOR BILLS LIKE THIS AND
WITH THAT HAPPY TO SUPPORT. ANY
FINAL COMMENTS FROM THE AUTHOR.
I LOVE THIS BILL MY HEART SINGS
AND I APPRECIATE IT'S AN HONOR
TO BE FOR THIS COMMITTEE
MISTREATMENT I THANK U. S. FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY
MOTION NEEDS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TRUTH HI CHIU I
SAY OCTOBER HI THE ALKALINE
GABRIEL. YEAH I KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN QUICK SILVA HI
FOLKS WHO BUY WEEKS. BILLS ON
CALL. LET'S NOT GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SENATE BILL THREE
ONE CENTER PORTANTINO WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME PRESENT SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
THE BILL WHICH MAKES CHANGES IN
THE DISPOSITION OF THE
DISPOSITION PROCESS OF THE S.
R. SEVEN TEN HOMES OWNED BY
CALTRANS AS YOU KNOW THIS IS
JUST BEEN A LITTLE SIXTY YEAR-
EXCURSION THE CALTRANS IS GONE
ON TO. BUILD THE FREEWAY THAN A
TUNNEL AND PLEASE THAT- I WAS
ABLE TO DO THE RIVER FAILED TO
TERMINATE THE TUNNEL AND NOW WE
HAVE THESE HOMES THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE GO INTO PROPER
DISPOSITION- SO SOUTH PASADENA
HAS EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES TO THE
CURRENT SALES PROCESS. THESE
CHANGES WOULD ALLOW FOR MORE
DIRECT IN THAT INTERVENTION BY
THE CITY IN PURCHASING AND
SHEPHERDING THE PROCESS IT WILL
GIVE TENANTS SINGLE FAMILY AND
MULTI FAMILY UNITS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT PURCHASE
AND GIVE CALTRANS A NINE MONTH
TIME LINE TO SELL. EITHER ON ON
OCCUPIED PROPERTIES IN THE CITY
OF SOUTH PASADENA I WOULD BE
SOLD ACQUISITION PRICE WITH A
FIFTY FIVE YEAR COVENANT ON THE
LAND TO ALLOW THE CITY OF
PASADENA TOURISTS SOUTH
PASADENA. ESTABLISHING TRANSFER
OWNERSHIP TO A CITY OF NON
HOUSING RELATED AN THAT WOULD
ACT AS A STORE OVER THE FALL
NEW AMENDMENTS AND THE M. OF
THE- SR SEVEN TEN FUND WHICH
HELP COUNTY MAKE FOR. ON THE
PROPERTIES- AND WOULD ALSO
WHERE WHERE THERE ARE TO DO
WITH THE ISSUE- TIMELY SO WE
THINK A GOOD ADJUSTMENT LASTLY
WOULD GRANDFATHER IN SALES
OFFERS WITH AN APPRAISAL MADE
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO FAIR
MARKET VALUE THIS WOULD MAKE
THE HOUSES MORE AFFORDABLE. FOR
THE TENANTS AND OBVIOUSLY I'M
GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
CALTRANS- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AS THIS BILL
HOPEFULLY GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE
AND MOVES ON IN THE PROCESS AND
I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE A WITNESS
AND SUPPORT. ON THE LINE AT
LEAST I HOPE AND AT THE PROPER.
TIME WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIVEAU. TO THE OPERATOR FORGET
PLEASE FROM. THE MAYOR SOUTH
PASADENA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS DIANA MAHMUD AND THE
MARE AND I AM PLEASED TO REPORT
THAT THIS CITY IS A SPONSOR
CHIU SB THREE EIGHTY ONE. AND
TWENTY NINETEEN SIX DECADES
HAVE ATTACKED TO CONSTRUCT AN
EXTENSION OF THE S. FIVE SEVEN
TEN FREEWAY THAT WOULD PASS
THROUGH THE STATURE AT SOUTH
PASADENA FINALLY AND THIS WITH
LEADERSHIP AND VALUABLE
ASSISTANCE AND SENATOR
PORTANTINO. BUT THE THREAT OF
THIS FAMILY EXTENSION BEHIND US
MY COMMUNITIES ATTENTION IS NOW
FOCUSED ON THE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES THAT CALTRANS
REQUIRED. FOR FREEWAY
CONSTRUCTION. MOST OF THE SIXTY
PROPER OWNED COUNTY. IN MY CITY
HAVE NOT BEEN WELL MAINTAINED
AND MANY ARE IN THE STATE OF
EXTREME DISREPAIR CALTRANS
FACES VERY IS BASICALLY AN EPIC
CONSEQUENCES OF GETTING THE
COLLECTED PROPERTIES. MOREOVER
MY CITY HAS BEEN DEPRIVED OF
PROPERTY TAX REVENUES WHICH FOR
MY SMALL SCREEN A HALF SQUARE
MILE CITY OF TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND POPULATION IS OUR
PRIMARY REVENUE SOURCE- DUE TO
CALTRANS OWNING SO MANY
PROPERTIES. SOUTH PASADENA HAS
LIVED WITH DECADES OF BLIGHTED
AND EXTRACTIVE NUISANCE TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE STATE IS NOW
PAYING FOR SECURITY TO GUARD
THE POUND FROM FURTHER DAMAGE
OR ILLEGAL OCCUPATION. SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE PROPOSES VERY
CHANGES TO THE EXISTING SURPLUS
DISPOSITION PROCESS THAT BETTER
SHIP MY COMMUNITY NEEDS AMONG
OTHER THINGS SB THREE EIGHTY
ONE WHAT DO THE FOLLOWING.
ENABLE CURRENT NON INCOME
QUALIFIED CANNONS THE PRIORITY
TO PURCHASE BEFORE ANY HOUSING
RELATED ENTITY SO THAT THEY CAN
REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT AS MANY
HAVE TOLD US THEY HAVE LIVED IN
THEIR HOMES FOR DECADES AND
HAVE LONG AWAITED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE THEIR
HOME. TO IT WOULD ALLOW THE
CITY THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PURCHASE ALL UNOCCUPIED
PROPERTIES AT CALTRANS REGIONAL
ACQUISITION PRICE THIS WOULD
PROVIDE THE SUBSTANTIAL FUNDS
NECESSARY TO RENOVATE
DILAPIDATED HOMES AND OFFER
THEM FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THREE IT WOULD ALLOW THE CITY
TO ESTABLISHING TRANSFER
OWNERSHIP OF REQUIRED HOMES TO
CITY PROVED NONPROFIT HOUSING
RELATED ENTITY SUCH AS A
COMMUNITY LAND TRUST TO PROVIDE
IT RESPONSIVE PROPERTY
MAINTENANCE AND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. FOUR I WOULD HAVE
MEANT TO GET THE NATIONAL
HISTORIC TO INCLUDE THOSE
PROPERTIES ON THE LOCALLY
DESIGNATED HISTORIC REGISTER
AND REQUIRED THAT REPAIRS
NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH OUR
LOCAL HISTORIC PRESERVATION
ORDINANCE BE FACTORED INTO THE
SALES PRICE. HAVING BEEN
INCORPORATED IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT MY CITY. IS FORTUNATE IN
HAVING MANY A- THAT DATE TO THE
EARLY OF THE CENTURY. A GOOD
NUMBER OF TOWN ARE LOW. IN THE
PROPOSED FREE BRIGHTER FOR AND
CHOIR TO FIND. FIVE THIS BILL
WOULDN'T SOMEBODY. PROPERTIES
TO BE SOLD AT FAIR MARKET
VALUES WITH THE NET PROCEEDS
EXCLUSIVELY USE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF THE HIGHER
COST OF RESTORING AND
MAINTAINING THESE HISTORIC
HOMES THE CITY CAN PROVIDE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IF IT
IS PERMITTED TO SELL THESE
PROPERTIES AT MARKET VALUE. AND
THEN ENSURE AND USE THE
PROCEEDS TO AFGHANISTAN. FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED IN MY STUDY.
SIX OF THE CURRENT TENANT IS
NOT QUALIFIER CHOOSES NOT TO
PURCHASE IT SAYS HOME SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE WOULD ALLOW THE CITY
TO PURCHASE THOSE PROPERTIES AT
THEIR ACQUISITION PRICE. MAKE
ALL THE NECESSARY REPAIRS AND
RENT THE PROPERTY BACK TO THE
CURRENT TENANT. AND FINALLY AT
LEAST IN TERMS OF MY SUMMARY
THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A TIME
FRAME FOR THE DISPOSITION
PROCESS WHICH IS TAKEN MUCH
LONGER THAN ANTICIPATED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION
I STRONGLY URGE A YES VOTE ON
THE BILL AND WELCOME ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM MAYOR LET'S NOW
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT WISH TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM NOR AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS- TO THE
OPERATOR GO BACK TO LINE IF
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THE FACT YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS A
WAR AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT AT THIS
TIME THERE IS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ALSO
LET'S AGAIN GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WISH TO STAY IN
OPPOSITION. KNOWN HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM OR THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION MADAM SIR-
OPERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO ACT THE
THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION THIS MINIMUM OF THE
BILL SECOND ANY DISCUSSION. TO
THE AUTHOR I KNOW WELL THAT-
THIS IS BEEN A LONG STANDING
ISSUE AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
AND OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN.
REALLY TRYING TO TACKLE OFF HOW
WE HANDLE THESE PROPERTIES ON
THE SEVEN TEN- AND- I KNOW YOU
ALSO BE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
CALTRANS TO. RECONCILE THE I
THINK- TWO OTHER BILLS- THAT
ARE MOVING FORWARD SO THAT WE
CAN- GET THESE PROPERTIES GOING
TO ADDRESS A HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WE HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
HI SOURCE AND- MY STAFF HAS
REALLY- I. HAD A VERY
PRODUCTIVE. CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOUR STAFF AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COLLABORATION-
THAT IS CUT GOT US TO THIS
POINT SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW MY STAFF IS
MENTIONED THAT MAKES SENSE. TO
ME SEVERAL TIMES AND APPRECIATE
YOUR- INTEREST AND OBVIOUSLY AS
YOU HEARD THE MAYOR. THIS IS
REALLY INTENDED TO PROTECT THE
TENANTS BUT ALSO TO CREATE. A
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN A COURT OR THE NEED
TO TELL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND- VERY
MUCH ALSO WANTED JUST THANK THE
WORK OF OUR GREAT COMMITTEE
STAFF- AND WITHOUT AND ALSO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
ON THIS- WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE.
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHU HI FEW I SAY
ARE NO TIME. YEAH HI. GABRIELLE
GABRIELLE I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. QUICKSILVER.
FORKS SILVA FIVE WEEKS. YOUR
BILL PASSES FIVE VOTES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. LET'S
NOT GO TO FOLLOW FIVE SB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR WELCOME
BACK. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY- PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN THIRTY FOR ITS- BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW. A COUNTIES TO
ENGAGE IN. OF IN EFFORTS TO
RESTRUCTURE REDEVELOPMENT
DEATH- THIS WOULD ALLOW US
CITIES TO HELP REORGANIZE TEST-
THEY EVENTUALLY- PRIOR TO- THE-
DISSOLUTION OF REDEVELOPMENT-
MANY CITIES ENTERED INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH COUNTIES THE
LAWS OF BIG WHETHER THEY CAN OR
RE SEAT AT THE TABLE AND
RESTRUCTURE. THESE AGREEMENTS-
THIS BILL ALLOWS THAT TO HAPPEN
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE. THAT CITIES
AND COUNTIES AND TURN TO THIS
CONVERSATION IT JUST ALLOWS IT
SHOULD. THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
BE INTERESTED IN- RESTRUCTURING
REDEVELOPMENT THAT UNDER THIS
AGREEMENT FORTY EIGHT POINT 9%
OF THE ART IS REVENUE. PASSED
THROUGH THE COUNTY AND FIFTEEN
POINT FIVE OF THE FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT- THE RDA
USE THE REMAINING 35% POINT 6%
THAT ALLOWED. REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES TO PAY DEBT- OR TO-
ENTER INTO DEBT. BY THE AGREE
THE AGREEMENTS ALSO INCLUDE
PROVISIONS FOR THE COUNTY TO
LONG THE RDA PARTS OF ITS PASS
THROUGHS. NECESSARY TO COMPLY
WITH EXISTING DEVELOPER
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS THESE
LOANS ACCRUED- INTEREST A 77%
COMPOUNDED PERCENT COMPOUNDED
ANNUALLY IN SOME CASES. AND
THIS WILL ALLOW AGAIN CITIES
TO- SIT DOWN AND RENEGOTIATE IT
IN IN ONE EXAMPLE AS OF TWENTY
NINETEEN THE CITY OF HUNTINGTON
PARK HAD AT THE TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN MILLION IN OUTSTANDING
PRINCIPAL AND INTEREST PAYMENTS
THEY'RE ONE OF THE CITIES THAT
ARE- FOR. CONTEMPLATING WORKING
WITH THEIR LOCAL COUNTY WITH
THE SUPPORT OF THE COUNTY SO.
THAT'SABOUT ONE INCH BY ONE
INCH ONE CASE WHERE THIS BILL
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL. SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. I HAVE
SOME WITNESSES ARNOLD OVER HIS
CLASSMEN AND STEVE CARMONA- ALL
ALSO WHAT ONE FOR. THE ATTORNEY
FOR SENDING THàNH PARK AND
ANOTHER THE CITY MANAGER FOR
PICKLE RIVERA TWO CITIES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL.
AMONG ANYMORE. THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY UTILIZE THIS BILL
TO HELP SAVE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
TO THE OPERATOR FOR COULD GO TO
THE MAIN WITNESSES. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ARNOLD
ALVAREZ GLASSMAN DOT GOV JIM
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM THE CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON PARK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON REGARDING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BATTLE CREEK NOT ONLY
OUR CITY BUT MANY OTHER CITIES
AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED. IN
TWENTY TWELVE ACTION WS TAKEN
BY THE STATE LEGISLATURE WHICH
RESULTED IN THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER SUCH ACTION
HAD A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT UPON
MANY CITIES WILL HAVE A
DISTINCT TAX PASS THROUGH
TREATMENTS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
ELIMINATES A KEY SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR RDAS TO RETAIN THE
OBLIGATIONS INCURRED BY THOSE
PASTORS PRIESTS. THE DIRECT
IMPACTS OF THE ELIMINATION OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES HAS
RESULTED IN MENTIONS BEING LEFT
WITH EXTRA SERVICE. OBLIGATIONS
HE- THE CITY RUNNING PART
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL IS AN EX.
CAN JUST YOURS WHO S. SEVEN
FOUR WE'LL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO NEGOTIATE A NETWORK
ACHIEVING. RELEASED FROM
SIGNIFICANT HIGH INTEREST RATES
ESTABLISHED IN THE PAST YEAR
AGREEMENTS WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE POSSIBLE REDUCTION. THE
PRINCIPAL OWED BY THE FORMER
RDAS IN CITIES TO THE COUNTY
AND OTHER TAXING ENTITIES. SB
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR RELIEF AND
RECOVERY. CURRENTLY UNDER
DEPEND THEIR PASTOR HUNTINGTON
PARK POSE AS MENTIONED.
PARTIALLY TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE HIGH
INTEREST RATES THESE NUMBERS
WILL CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET. SB
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR PROVIDES
MECHANISM FOR A LEVEL FIELD I'M
NEGOTIATION TO REDUCE THESE
AMOUNTS BY UP TO TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. INTO ADJUSTING
INTEREST RATES FROM THE RANGE.
OF 7% OR MORE DOWN TO ZERO. SB
SEVEN FORTY POINT MAKING THE-
STABILITY OF SAID AND TO
PROTECT THOSE WHO PAY THEIR
TAXES DURING THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES. WE BELIEVE THAT SB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR IS A BALANCED
APPROACH IS A GOOD START A MUCH
NEEDED COURSE OF ACTION TO
ADDRESS THE SIGNIFICANT
OBLIGATIONS. OF THE FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES UNDER
THESE PASS THROUGH PAYMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE I TOLD SB.
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. IF WE GET
HERE FROM THE SECOND ONE IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ANGELINA
CRISTEA THAT DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES THAT
THE CITY OF PICO RIVERA
REPRESENTING MISTER STEVE
CARMANAH CITY MANAGER. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY- IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR. WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL AS
THIS IS LEGISLATION BUSINESS
LEGISLATION IS CRITICAL IN
PROTECTING OUR FISCAL SOLVENCY.
AND BY PROVIDING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REENGAGE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF I'M
SORRY RENEGOTIATE THAT MEXICAN
AMOUNTS OF DEBT ACCRUED TO THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES. THIS IS
A DIFFICULT THING THAT I HAD
OVER THE YEARS ENTERED INTO
SEVERAL PASSED TO AGREEMENTS
WITH THE CITY COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. WE CURRENTLY OWE ABOUT
FORTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS BUT
NEARLY ONE THIRD REPRESENTING
INTEREST. WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MODIFY THE
INTEREST RATE ON THIS DEBT FROM
THE 7% THE CITY CURRENTLY A
CRUISE DOWN TO ZERO AS WELL AS
ASK THAT 25% OF THE PRINCIPAL
AMOUNT OUT OF OUTSTANDING
DEFERRED PASSED THROUGH PAYMENT
OWED BY THE- FORMER ID EIGHT RT
EIGHT TO THE TAXING ENTITY. IN
ADDITION THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE RELIEF TO US AN
UNDERPRIVILEGED COMMUNITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ALSO RENEGOTIATE
PLEDGED PROPERTY TAXES SALES
TAXES OR OTHER LOCAL REVENUE
SOURCES TOWARDS REPAYMENT OF
HESE COMPOUNDING AND DECADE
OLD. DEFERRAL APPLICATION THIS
WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO STRUCTURE
THE EXISTING OBLIGATION AN
EQUITABLE WAY AND ENSURE FUTURE
TAX INCREMENT REVENUES GO
TOWARD INVESTMENT. IN ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CITY THANK
YOU AGAIN. LET'S NOT GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM OR THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION- GOING
BACK TO THE OPERATOR. OF FOUR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THEY WISH
TO STATE THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ARAFAT STEVE
SEVEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU THERE IS NO MAN OPPOSITION
WITNESS- KNOWN HERE AND OF THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. WISHING TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION OR AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION- TO
THE OPERATOR ANY MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WISH TO STATE.
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
DISCUSSION. THIS NOTION WITH
THE BILLS ARE SECOND. THEIR
SECOND WITH THE BILL. THERE'S
BEEN A SECOND ANY FINAL
COMMENTS BY THE AUTHOR I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORT IN THIS MATTER LAST FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. I WANT TO JUST
SAY THAT- SINCE. REDEVELOPMENT
WAS DISSOLVED- THERE BEEN MANY
ISSUES THAT HAVE CONTINUED
EVEN. OVER A DECADE LATER- AND
APPRECIATE THIS AUTHOR ALONG
WITH OTHERS IN RECENT YEARS TO.
CONTINUE ADDRESS CHALLENGES
THAT HAVE RESULTED FROM THE
DISSOLUTION AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL- AND WITH
THAT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TRUE HI CHIU I
SAY ARCO. HI SAY ART BY.
GABRIEL GABRIEL I KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN CORK
SILVA. COXHILL FIVE WEEKS. YOUR
BILL PASSES WITH FIVE VOTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND WITH THAT
AT THIS TIME I THINK WE'VE GOT
ONE FINAL AUTHOR. AND WE WILL
WAIT FOR SENATOR CORTEZ HE.
WE'LL DO AROUND OF ADAMS RIGHT
NOW MADAM SECRETARY. LET'S JUST
START WITH JUST GO THROUGH THE
ROLE- FILE AND ONE S. B. TWELVE
MCGUIRE ANY OF MEMBERS DON'T.
OKAY THAT BILL IS ON CALL FINAL
FINAL AM. TO CALL HAVE SOME
MEMBERS. BURKE I MAIN FRANKLY.
RIGHT FIVE THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES AND IT PASSES FILE ITEM
THREE. BOOKSELLERS CAR KALRA I
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN WICKS TWENTY
BUCKS AND I THINK ALL THE REST
OF THE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN HERE
FOR SO WHEN I GO TO OUR FINAL
TWO ITEMS. WE HAVE GOOD CENTER
FROM SANTA CLARA FILE ITEM
SEVEN S. B. SEVEN EIGHTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF TODAY I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT.
SB SEVENTY THE ABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT CHANGES IN THE
ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCE
DISTRICT III IF THESE LONG
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION
INVESTMENT AUTHORITIES ALSO
KNOWN AS C. R. HE'S STILL
CITIES USE THESE TOOLS TO
FINANCE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. SINCE THE ELIMINATION
OF REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES. IN
TWENTY ELEVEN THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED SEVERAL TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS TO SUPPORT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO ADDRESS
OUR HOUSING CRISIS. YEAH FT'S
AND CRA'S HAVE EMERGED AS TOOLS
OF ALL LOCAL AGENCIES TO USE A
TAX INCREMENT. OF PARTICIPATING
ENTITIES TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS.
HOWEVER THE MIDDLE OF TAKE. OF
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS IS PROOF
THAT THEY'RE OVERLY CUMBERSOME
CURRENTLY TO ESTABLISH AND
OPERATE. WITH A HOUSING CRISIS
RAVAGING CITIES AND COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE REVITALIZATION
OF THESE TOOLS WILL REDUCE SB
SEVENTY MAKES SEVEN EIGHTY.
MAKE SEVERAL CHANGES TO BOTH
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ENABLE LOCAL
AGENCIES TO USE THESE TOOLS TO
EFFECTIVELY STIMULATE
DEVELOPMENT IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AMONG OTHER MINOR
CHANGES THE BILL STREAMLINES
PROCESS FOR MANY IN EXISTING
PLANTS A RE WRITES THE TENURE
PROTEST PROCESS IN C. R. I. A
LAW TO MAKE CRA HE'S IN THE- IF
THESE MORE VIABLE FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO CREATE AND OPERATE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THIS GROUP AXEL HOTEL FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THE
MICHAELEEN FROM SPUR. DAN KIRK
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
WILL ALSO BE AVAILABLE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. LET'S GO TO
THE MAIN WITNESSES TO THE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU DON'T LINES
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS GO
BACK TO HOTEL AND I SERVE THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
CALIBRATE PRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPERS AND
STAKEHOLDERS THERE'S A BIT FROM
THE GRANT PROFESSIONAL HELPING
BUSINESSES THRIVE GROWING LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA.
OUR MEMBERS UNDERSTAND VALUE
AND BENEFIT THE TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING CAN BRING THE LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
INCLUDING HELPING SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SOLUTIONS AS
WELL AS BUILDING AND REPAIRING
INFRASTRUCTURE. MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE EXPLORING THE
AREA THE FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ESPECIALLY NOW AS
WE WORK TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND OTHERS ARE CONSIDERING CREE
AS BECAUSE OF THEIR SPECIFIC
FOCUS ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE LAST BALL CHALAKUDY IN THE
WORKING GROUP OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PRACTITIONERS TO
REVIEW THE EXISTING TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOL. AND
THEIR SUGGESTION IMPROVEMENTS
TO MAKE THESE TOOLS MORE
WORKABLE ARE CONTAINED IN SB
SEVEN EIGHTY AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF DETAIL THOSE SPECIFICALLY
ANALYSIS AS WELL. WE APPRECIATE
CENTER CORTESE UNIT STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH KHALLID ON THESE
ISSUES WELL THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR DETAILED REVIEW
OF THE DEL INCLUDING WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THE CASHIER NUMBERS
MICHAEL AND OF STRAWBERRY
PLAINS RESEARCH ASSOC A PUBLIC
POLICY THINK TANK NOTICE BURKE.
THIS WAS THE PLACE OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IN
TWENTY ELEVEN ALL OF US TO
SPENT THE PAST DECADE WORKING
REPLACEMENT TOOLS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COME ALLOW FOR
BROWN TO REMEDIATION.
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS AND
UPGRADES ASSEMBLAGE OF PARCEL
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. REPORTER THE IFC'S
SECRETOS NIPPED IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AUTHORITIES IN ORDER TO
RECREATE AT LEAST SOME OF THE
ADVOCACY OF THE TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING PREVIOUSLY AVAILABLE.
UNFORTUNATELY ONE AWARE OF
DOZENS OF JURISDICTIONS ARE
TAKING A HARD LOOK AT THE NET
BEAT DISTRICTS USING THESE TIPS
TOOLS ONLY A HANDFUL OF FOLLOW
THROUGH DUST UNDERLINED THE
NEED. TO IMPROVE AND PERFECT
THESE TOOLS SB SEVEN A. WILL
MAKE THE IRAQIS INCREASE MORE
USER FRIENDLY AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IS NEEDED NOW TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE MORE WIDELY
ADOPTED. BY BOTH THANK YOU.
LET'S NOT GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- THERE'S
NO ONE HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM OR AT THE REMOTE.
TESTIMONY STATIONS LET'S OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINES FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO WISH TO STATE
THEIR SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. IS
SEVEN EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FOUR LINES
LINK YOU WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MODERATE HOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK HEARING
ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU'RE A MEMBER NECRO ON BEHALF
OF LEGAL CALIFORNIA CITY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROB BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. SB. SEVEN
NINETY. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SIX FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE JIMENEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FORWARD ACTION FUND IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TWO OR NO MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESS- KNOWN HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM OR THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS TO
TESTIFY AGAINST THIS BILL LET'S
NOW OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES IF
THERE ANY MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
THEY WISH TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
EIGHTY PLEASE PESS ALIGNMENT
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS. IS OUR MOTION OF THIS
BEFORE. THE MOTION AND A
SECOND- I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR. LOOKING AT HOW
WE THINK ABOUT- PUBLIC
FINANCING OPTIONS TO MOVE
FORWARD HOUSING. AND AT THIS
TIME WE KNOW THAT THEIR DAD
JUST A LOT OF CHALLENGES AND
HOW WE USE EXISTING TOOLS AND-
APPRECIATE- HIS WORK TO UPDATE
WHAT WE HAVE IN OUR TOOL KIT TO
MAKE THINGS MORE EFFICIENT AND-
APPRECIATE THIS BUILDING A GOOD
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY. ANY FINAL
COMMENTS-GO AGAIN THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MADAM
SECRETARY GENERAL. MOTION IS TO
PASS YOU BY CHU HI SAY R. TWO
NINE BY W. W. AYE KALRA. AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
COOK SILVA. KOKE. SILVA I WEEKS.
SIXTEENTH YOUR BILL HAS VOTES
AND A PASSES AND- FINAL
PRESENTATION TODAY WILL BE THE
YEAR SB SEVEN NINETY ONE FILE
ITEM EIGHT. CENTER OKAY THANK
YOU AGAIN AND- THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB SEVEN NINETY ONE. WHICH
CREATES A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
UNIT. WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
HOUSING COMMITTEE BELLMAN IN
ORDER FACILITATE THE
CONSTRUCTION FOR ABOUT HOUSING
ON THE LOCAL SURPLUS LAND.
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES CONTROL
THOUSANDS OF SURPLUS SITES.
MANY OF WHICH OF SUCH BACON FOR
YEARS DUE TO THE NUMEROUS
BARRIERS LOCAL AGENCIES FACE IN
GETTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BILLS. SUCH AS LACK OF CAPACITY
IN FINANCING EXPERTISE. IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
TO MINISTRATION HAVE SET THE
GROUNDWORK FOR UTILIZING UNUSED
PUBLIC LAND. TO PROMOTE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
FOR GOVERNOR EXECUTIVE ORDER IN
TWENTY NINETEEN CREATED A SMALL
TEAM OF STAFF TO FACILITATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ON APPROPRIATE STATE
OWNED EXCESS LAND. DISLEY
RECENTLY PASSED LEGISLATION
REQUIRED EACH CITY AND COUNTY
TO REPORT EIGHT CD IN INVENTORY
BUT SURPLUS LANDS BY APRIL THIS
YEAR. THIS IS MEASURES HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE HCD HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMED WITH CALLS FROM
LOCAL AGENCIES ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE IN DISPOSING OF THE
SURPLUS LAND. INFORMATIONAL
LOCAL SURPLUS SITES COMING THIS
MONTH. WILL ONLY INCREASE OUR
WORKLOAD. THE STATE MUST TAKE
MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL AGENCIES
AND GETTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUILT ON SURPLUS LAND. THIS
BILL ACHIEVES THIS BY CREATING
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE UNIT
WITHIN A CD THAT WILL
FACILITATE THE DEVELOPMENT
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE UNIT WILL PROVIDE
ADVICE. TECHNICAL AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL AGENCIES
WITH SURPLUS LAND OF COURSE AND
VOTERS THAT SEEK TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON THOSE
SITES. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
UNIT TO SUBMIT A ROBUST ANNUAL
REPORT THAT WILL PROVIDE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION IN THE
BREAKDOWN OF FUNDING SOURCES
FOR ASSISTED HOUSING UNITS. SB
SEVENTY SEVEN NINETY ONE. HAS
THE ENDORSEMENT OF SENATE
HOUSING PRODUCTION WORK GROUP
WILL SERVICE THE NEXT UP FOR
INCREASING HOUSING PRODUCTION
ON UNUSED PUBLIC LANDS. LIKE TO
THINK THAT YOU'RE A COMMITTEE
CONSOLES FOR THE DILIGENT WORK
BEGINNING THIS BILL READY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF STEVE
CRUZ REPRESENT THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE. THANK YOU IN A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR LET'S GO TO MISTER
CHRIS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HI STEVE
CREATING CRESCENTA USE ON
BEHALF OF MAYOR SAM LICCARDO
FIRST YOU LIKE THANK YOU
SENATOR CORTESE FOR INTRODUCING
THE MEASURE. HAS THE LARGEST
CITY IN THE SOUTHEAST REGION
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE HAS MADE A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO
ACCELERATING HOUSING PRODUCTION
WITH CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE
HOUSING CRISIS RAVAGING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IT
IS CRITICAL THAT WE USE ALL
AVAILABLE TOOLS AND STRATEGIES
TO ADDRESS. THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE WE BELIEVE SB SEVENTY
ONE REPRESENTED CREATED A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THIS ORDER SHORTAGE BY CAREER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE UNITS WITH
A CD WHICH CITIES CAN
VOLUNTARILY ACCESS THOSE
FACILITATE HOUSING PROTECTION
ON LAND THE CITY THAT REQUIRED
SURPLUS THIS UNIT WILL PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY EXPERTISE TO HELP
OUR CITY. AND MANY OTHER CITIES
PUT TOGETHER AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS MORE QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY ON THEIR SURPLUS
LAND. FOR THESE REASONS
pLET'S NOT GO TO THE- ACT THE C.
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SAY NINE OR AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATIONS. TO THE
OPERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO SUPPORTS THIS BILL. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AT THE END ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
LINES IN Q. RIGHT ONE SIXTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MARK STIVERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS BRING
THIS WONDERFUL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE DAILY GATWICK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THERE IS NO
MAIN OPPOSITION WITNESS- DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM TO OPPOSE THE
BILL OR AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD- ALLOW ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IT WISHES TO STATE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO DO SO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
NINETY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY LET'S
BRING BACK TO THE COMMUNITY
DISCUSSION MISTER KALRA. IT'S
BEEN A MOTION WITH THE BILL.
HIS ARE SECOND AND I WILL
SECOND THAT AND ALSO ASK IF I
CAN BE A JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS
AS I THINK IT'S A REALLY
PROFOUND THE BILL. I ALSO HAVE
A COMPANION BILL ON- ON
EIGHTEEN SURPLUS LAND BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW WHETHER IT'S LOCAL
OR STATE WE'RE CERTAINLY NOT
BUILDING ENOUGH. AND I REALLY
LIKE SEEN ON THIS BILL THAT YOU
HAVE THE TRADES. AND THE
VILLAGERS AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS NOT ALWAYS
ON THE SAME PAGE SO I THINK
THAT THIS. MIGHT BE AN AREA
WHERE WE CAN REALLY MAKE
PROGRESS SO I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK SENATOR. YEAH MISTER
RESTAURANT YEAH. I'M NOT
OPPOSED TO THE UNIT THEY NEED
TRYING TO ASSESS IT BUT THE
LAND- ACQUISITION PART OF THIS
HAS RUN INTO SOME PROBLEMS WITH
SOME CITIES THAT I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR REPRESENTING-
AND I THINK THAT THEY NEED TO
BE WORKED ON A BIT- SPECIALLY
WHEN. WE HAVE CITY OWNED LAND
THAT'S SURROUNDED IN A CIVIC
CENTER- THAT NOW HAS TO GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO. DO IT HAS LONG
BEEN PLANNED FOR THAT AREA SO-
SO I'M NOT NECESSARILY- OPPOSED
TO TRYING TO HAVE THAT THE
OTHER PARTS OF IT FACILITATED.
BY THE LAND USE THING ITSELF I
THINK NEEDS TO BE WORKED ON SO
THANK YOU IT MAY A THROUGH THE
CHAIR RESPOND PLEASE FIRST OF
ALL LET ME VERIFY MAY TAKE THIS
OF THE PREVIOUS ORDER HERE TO
SAY- WOULD BE PLEASED TO HAVE
YOU AS A CO AUTHOR OF A SOME
REAL QUICK SILVA- IMPACT YOUR-
QUESTIONS THE NEW YORK THE FOR.
ASSEMBLYMAN A PER VERSION OF
THE BILL- HAD ACQUISITION
LANGUAGE IN IT THAT IS- BEEN
AMENDED OUT OF THE BILL- THE
THINGS THAT I DESCRIBED FOR
WHAT'S LEFT IN THE BILL SO TO
SPEAK TECHNICAL ADVICE- IN
CONSULTATION IT IS NOT
MANDATORY IS COMPLETELY
VOLUNTARY. SO WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE A RESOURCE FOR THOSE.
COULD SCHOOL DISTRICT COULD BE.
SMALLER CITIES THAT DON'T HAVE
THEIR OWN HOUSING DEPARTMENTS
AND SO FORTH- THAT ARE THAT ARE
LOOKING FOR. SOMEBODY THAT CAN
POINT THEM IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION- SECONDLY- IT REALLY
SHOULDN'T I THINK I COVERED
THAT MY COMMENTS AS FAR BUT-
THERE REALLY SHOULDN'T BE ANY
REASON. THAT THE CITY FOR
EXAMPLE- DOESN'T PROCEED UNDER
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT EXACTLY
HOW IT'S DESIGNED CURRENTLY
THERE'S NOTHING HERE THAT
CHANGES OR AMENDS THE RULES OR
IMPACTS- THE SURPLUS LAND THAT
CAN I JUST WANNA MAKE THAT
CLEAR THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CONFUSION. I KNOW SOMETIMES WE
INTRODUCE- INITIAL LANGUAGE ON
A BILL ACROSS IT- BEFORE WE
AMENDED THEN AND HAVE WORDS
LIKE ACQUISITION AND IT OF
COURSE IS GONNA- YOU KNOW RAISE
SOME EYEBROWS AND SOME CONCERNS
BUT AGAIN THAT THAT THE- TICKET
LIKE AGAIN I COMMENDED THE
COMMITTEE AND THE CHAIR. OF FOR
WORKING WITH ME CLOSELY TO- TO
GET THAT LANGUAGE TAKEN CARE OF.
SHE TRANSFER THANK. THANK YOU I
JUST WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
GIVEN ON THIS- I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT IN RECENT YEARS THERE
BEEN A NUMBER OF BILLS TO
REALLY LOOK AT HOW WE CAN BEST
USE SURPLUS LAND IN THE STATE
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT FOR A LOT
OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT- IT HAS NOT BEEN THE
EASIEST TO FIGURE OUT TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD AND- I THINK
MOVING FORWARD- THE IDEA OF A
DEDICATED UNIT EIGHT CD TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
AGENCIES CITIES DEVELOPERS. AND
HOW TO UTILIZE SURPLUS LANDS
FOR HOUSING IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD AND- THERE WILL
LIKELY BE OTHER STEPS AFTER
THIS BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO FOR TO MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION SO HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR WORK ANY FINAL
COMMENTS- KNOW ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU AND- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR UNCLE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION NEEDS TO FAST AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS ISSUE HI TRUE PI
CE ARCO NO NO. HIGHLY NO
MAIENSCHEIN KIRK SILVA HI FOLKS
WHO FIVE WEEKS WICKS I. YOUR
BILL PASSES WITH FIVE VOTES
THANK YOU OKAY AGAIN THANK YOU
ALL THANK YOU MR RIGHT. LET'S
GO BACK THROUGH THE ROLE I
THINK MR MAIN TRANSIT POLICE ON
IN THIS BUT- WE CAN JUST GET
DONE- WITH THE RECEIVER HERE-
MADAM SECRETARY YOU WANNA JUST
GO THROUGH FROM THE TOP OF THE
ORDER. FILE ITEM ONE SB TWELVE
MCGUIRE. KILEY. YEAH KILEY LOW
MAIENSCHEIN. FOR WE HAVE FOR
ICE TO- KNOWS ONE MEMBER NUMBER
SO THAT BILL IS ON CALL FILE
I'D TO STERN SB SIXTY. HIGHLY I
HIGHLY I MAIENSCHEIN WICKS I
THAT WOULD BE SO. SEVEN ICE
ZERO THAT BILL- PASSES SOME
VOTE- WE HAVE MISTER MAN HERE
SO ONE WE OF FOLLOWED TO SB
SIXTY STERN MR MATRON. AND THEN
FOR FILE ITEM ONE THIS IS SB
TWELVE MCGUIRE. MR MAJOR NOT
ONLY. HAVE YOU HEARD THAT YES
NUMBER FOURTEEN I'M SORRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
DOWNLOADING. SO FOR FILE ITEM
ONE THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES AND
FEELS OF THIS TIME AND AT THIS
POINT WE WILL NOTICE
RECONSIDERATION FOR- MISTER
MICHAEL. MISPRINT
RECONSIDERATION FOR MISTER
REQUIRE AS FOR UNANIMOUS
CONSENT FOR THAT. OKAY WE'VE
DONE FILE AND ONE AND TWO FILE
ITEM THREE S. B. THREE FOUR
FOUR HERTZBERG. KILEY FIVE
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE WEEKS WEEKS BY.
WILL BE EIGHT TWO ZERO. THE
BILL PASSES FILE ITEM FOR SB
THREE EIGHTY ONE PORTANTINO
KILEY KILEY HI MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN I. WICKS WICKS
FIVE. EIGHT TWO ZERO THE BILL
PASSES FALLEN FIVE SB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR FOUR SO. KILEY
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN AYE WICKS WICKS HI
EIGHT TWO ZERO. THE BILL PASSES-
THE CONSENT ON FILE ITEM SIX SB
SEVEN FORTY THREE CALLED APPS
MEMBERS GABRIEL GABRIEL I KILEY
AYE KILEY I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN NINE. TWO ZERO. THE
BILL PASSES OF VIOLENCE SEVEN
S. B. SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
COURTESY. MAIENSCHEIN HI
MAIENSCHEIN NINE WEEKS WEEKS
FIVE EIGHT TWO ZERO THE BILL
PASSES AND FIND ITEM FILING
EIGHT SB SEVEN NINETY ONE
COURTESY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN I THINK I. SIX I
TO- KNOWS THAT BILL PASSES AS
WELL. CAN WITHOUT OUR BUSINESS
FOR THIS COMMITTEE IS DONE FOR
THE DAY AND WE ARE TURNED.